maybe you think i'm being premature but
in this moment can i suggest we also
dare to hope for a spirit of celebration
to emerge sometime later this year
to use a wartime analogy as i've done
previously
we might not have our ve day yet but we
can rejoice in the overwhelming success
of d-day
now as in 1944 the british people need
some good news
we all need to believe that one day soon
the war on covid will be over
in the book of hosea we read this
i will deliver this people from the
power of the grave i will redeem them
from death
where o death are your plagues
where o grave is your destruction
as ever if you're not a person of faith
uh please use these brief moments to
think and reflect on these things in
your own way
let's pray
our father we thank you that the tide is
beginning to turn against covet 19.
may this bold promise of hope that the
prophet hosea speaks of be fulfilled in
our time
we thank you for those who have been
stewarding vaccination center car parks
checking people in
administering injections and wiping down
chairs afterwards
as the herd immunity slowly builds in
our community we pray that the
long-awaited recovery phase can begin
but in this help us to remember that
there was great celebration at the end
of the second world war
and this came first
before the long process began of
rebuilding our damaged cities and
rebuilding our traumatized community
help us to begin to think about marking
the moment when the all clear is finally
sounded
and help us to plan to create spaces
together
to allow people to do what they need to
do first
celebrate and rejoice
under john's wisdom and impartial
sharing please direct and guide this
council to take their part in this group
excuse me in this great united effort to
pull together for the common good
choosing to lay aside
both personal preference and party
politics politics wherever a spirit of
oneness would be preferable
for everyone's sake
we thank you for hearing our prayers
feeding us with your word and
encouraging us in our meeting together
in jesus name amen
amen
mark thank you very much indeed for for
that mark we chatted briefly yesterday
and i know you have to leave the meeting
shortly but you advised me yesterday
that your mum had sadly passed away
i'm confident that the members and staff
of team bridge district council will
join me in offering our sincere
condolences to you and your family at
this difficult time bless you john thank
you
chair we are live streaming now so thank
you thank you much today for that folks
so beth could you could do a roll call
please
counselor austin
councillor bradford
president
councillor bill event
councillor clarence president
cancer colclough
present
councillor connect
councillor david cox president
councillor hugh cox president
councillor dawes
i'm here
councillor dewhurst
president
councillor eden
she's logging in
thank you
councillor evans
president
councillor foden
presents
councillor goodman bradbury
present councillor gribble
councillor haines
president
councillor hayes
councillor hawking
council gordon hook
president
councillor jackie hook
councillor jeffrey president
councillor jeffries
president
counselor jenks
present
counselor keeling
present
catch the kurzweil
president
cancer mcgregor
present
that's cancer morgan
present
cancer malone
present
cancer natalie president
councillor
president
councillor
president
council parker khan
president
cancer patch
president
council pete
president
council linda pedreck president
cancer persa
council russell
councillor swain
present
councillor taylor
council parker
thank you thank you very much
meeting protocols just a few points to
mention uh would you please ensure your
microphone is on mute when you are not
speaking
if you wish to address the council
please raise your electronic hand
they will appear on my screen in the
sequence that they are raised and i will
i will go through them in the correct
order please keep your camera on during
the actual meeting should a comfort
bakery required members are asked to
switch both camera and microphone off
for the break period
the agenda is quite a lengthy agenda
today and i would anticipate that we're
going to have a comfort break probably
in about one and a half hours time
uh apologies for absence please
counselor sheila cook
councillor phipps
thank you
thank you
item two uh the minutes of the full
council on the 14th of january
would something like propose that we
would we can accept those minutes please
oppose chairman
thank you and a second to please
i'll be the second chair
okay so proposed and seconded so could
we go to the vote on that please a roll
call please beth
councillor bradford
abstain
council bill evans
paul
that's a clarence or
councillor colclough
council connect
council david cox or
councillor hugh cox
councillor dawes
abstain
cancer dewhurst for
councillor eden
councillor evans
councillor foden
answered goodman bradbury for
councillor gribble
or
councillor haines
or
councillor hayes
or
councillor hawking
cancer gordon hook
paul
councillor jackie hook
or
cancer jeffrey
councillor jeffries
or
councillor jenks
or
cancer keeling
or
cancer care as well
or
cancer mcgregor
four
council morgan
oh
cancer malone
sorry for
councillor natalie or
cancer nuttel
or
councillor orm
oh
that's a parker khan
or
cancer patch
abstain
council pets
four
council linda pedreck
thorne or
cancer wrigley
or
cancer parker
or
cancer john petherick yeah
[Music]
thank you thank you that's carriage chad
i just wanted to check because
councillor uh gary taylor's joined us so
um i understand
um
were you voting on this one councillor
taylor
okay it's carried anyway chair okay
thank you very much indeed for that
thank you
um announcements um
team i'm very very proud and privileged
to announce that team bridge council
have made a successful bid application
to the department of business
energy and industrial strategy for local
authority delivery of green home grants
we have been awarded 1 million
147 500 pounds to provide 100 air source
heat pumps to householders in team
bridge targeting fuel poor homes this
funding will help 100 households improve
their heating systems help save money on
energy bills reduce fuel poverty and
reduce carbon emissions i think you'd
agree this is a giant leap forward for
this council
additionally
uh it's been i've chosen to revise the
agenda i did send an email out on friday
which i'll read to you know i've decided
to move agenda item 15 which is the
constant
the constitution working group update
and agenda item 16 which is notices of
motions up the agenda as the issues
these items raise go to the core of
constitutional issues and good
governance they will be taken after
agenda item seven which is the final
financial plan proposals
are there any declarations of interest
chairman i raised my hand oh i do
i declare an apologi in item 14. um i've
been a friend and colleague of sheila
cooks for 34 years in king's curse or
frequently visited her house until
obviously recent uh
situation
and i feel that i i should have a
personal interest so i shall not speak
or vote on that item
thank you councillor haynes that's
understandable councillor jewhorst
you're muted i am
thank you thank you chair yes i i i also
um i'm a personal friend of councillor
sheila cook um although i've not known
her for nearly as long as councillor
haines
and i also won't be voting or speaking
thank you for that
item six on the agenda
sorry item five on the agenda apologies
is public questions i understand that we
have two members of the public that were
in the waiting room and i guess they're
no actually in the meeting
chair yes mr mr ray and mr uh dudley
swain have been um
getting to the meeting now so they're
they're here okay well thank you uh
copies of these questions together with
the answers from the the officers or
members have been circulated today
um so the first question the first
member of the public mr ray
uh mr ray can you hear me okay yes i can
splendid okay so uh your your question
one has been responded by um the
executive member for planning you
received that response presumably
uh no
um
i sent it out uh this morning about half
of seven
on an email
right
okay
okay um
the best thing then for is for um us to
read the question and the response out
chair are you able to do that have you
got that in front of you yes i have yes
okay thank you
so okay mr ray so your first question
was i would like to ask the question
regarding planning enforcement
or more to the point lack of enforcement
it appears at the moment that abuse of
the planning regulations and operating
without planning permission it's being
overlooked
or given a very low priority
some cases involve major issues such as
road safety pollution flooding the
environment etc and are not being
looked at for months and in some cases
years as this is a dangerous situation
to be in could you please give me some
idea what time schedule the public can
expect from reporting an incident to
action being taken by the enforcement
officer i fully understand that covid
makes them jobs very difficult to carry
out but in this instance when most cases
are outside
a site visit can be carried out with
social distancing and in safety
the member for executive member sorry
the executive member for planning has
responded
i have your response here councillor
taylor would you like to respond or
should i read your response out
[Music]
the applicant to two
details on our website
uh
but in in answer to the
in answer to the question
also i can i can add that uh
what it says on our website is that we
investigate all reasonable complaints
prioritizing them accordingly to their
urgency and the potential harm depending
on priority you may not receive an
update for several weeks and of course
that's the situation now we have with
with kobit we will act proportionately
taking enforcement action where
appropriate to remedy harm and where it
is in the wider public interest
so
i would uh uh refer the uh
the member of public to to the question
to to the answer that that i gave and uh
you can follow that follow the
information through on on the website
uh looking in particular at uh
planning enforcement policy and planning
enforcement process thank you chad
thank you councillor taylor so mr ray if
you've had a response to that question
would you like to ask a supplementary
question
uh yes i would um
it's that uh
could the council assure me that the
use of certificates of lawfulness
will not be used to reduce the workload
of the planning department
and that if they are used a full
investigation will be made as to the
validity of the applicant's claims
and if they're found to be untruthful
the certificate will be denied and a
planning application will have to be
made through the normal channels
uh thank you mr ray councillor taylor i
would you like to respond no or it's
happy to respond to that uh
so we've moved from enforcement uh onto
planning matters and certificates of law
from this are are
an open process that people can comment
on uh through the planning process
uh so so i can assure uh the member
public that uh yes uh or
the full the full uh
um
uh
application will will be looked at and
will be able to be commented upon and
will be acted on an officer accordingly
okay thank you councillor taylor so mr
ray your second question um is i see on
the team bridge district council website
that the tdc constitution has been
revised could you tell me why this was
done and what consultation was carried
out before the implementation when i
have responded to that uh mr ray but you
obviously say you haven't received the
response so i'll read it out to you now
this was done in accordance with the
resolution of full council september
2019
and it includes a computer link which
i'm not going to read you know but you
will see it when you get the email the
report together with the recommendations
was published on the council website
five working days before that meeting in
line with legislation to allow the
public and members to speak so to allow
the public and members to read the
documents and to submit questions number
received on this report so that's my
response to your question too do you
have a supplementary question
which which must arise from from the
original question sir yes well i i did
have it but you've actually answered
that question i was i was going to ask
if um
if it would if it had gone before a full
council meeting
and you've answered that that it has so
okay thank you for that okay thank you
mr ray thank you for attending um we
have another two questions from from
members of the public when we finish the
questions the members of public you will
be asked to leave the meeting but if you
wish to continue watching the meeting
you can watch it live on youtube so okay
okay thank you thank you
so the next question is from mr baker
i'm saying that mr baker is not present
sorry not present not present
so the questions have been circulated so
hopefully uh mr baker has received a
response as well
so we don't need to discuss that one any
further do
we so the the third member of the public
uh mr swain
mr swain
can you hear me yes i can good morning
spend it good morning to you um
have you now you've asked three
questions
yes and you've received responses this
morning no but i've i happen to have
looked at the agenda and i can see the
attachment so i've got the answers
oh you've got the answers okay so so the
first question you've had a response
from the executive member for corporate
services would you like to ask a
supplementary which arises from the
original question yes please
carry on
um the parish it says here the parish
has the opportunity to replace the staff
of course it's not the staff that they
replace they replace the officers
but i'm led to believe that the
replacement process is going to be the
may 2023's elections
um this means that the parish council
cannot now close the accounts at the end
of the year and therefore an audit can't
take place
this means that any financial or
procedural irregularities
will not be managed since this is public
money is teambridge content with this
situation
member for corporate services are you
are you able to answer that question or
would you like to provide a written
response
uh thank you mr chairman um
to be correct i'll give a written
response to that
okay thank you
uh mr swain your second question you
received uh an executive sorry every
report a response from the executive
member for corporate services
would you like to ask a secondary sorry
a supplementary question which arises
from your first question
uh no uh the the answer you have given
is uh what i would call unsatisfactory
but i understand it's the answer
splendid thank you for that and then
question three um you received a
response from the leader would you like
to ask the supplementary yes please
please go ahead
um i see that the uh
a notice of motion will be debated later
in the meeting my question hinges around
precisely this because is the debate
going to be sound in the absence of
comment from talc uh particularly since
talc is endorsed and supported as lily
is an organization between all parish
and town councils and team bridge
uh well i mean i can partially respond
to that one because it's not necessarily
going to be debated uh the the mover of
the uh noticed a motion can present it
to the council and the council when
decide whether we debate it or not and
to debate it two-thirds of the council
have to be in agreement
uh but i'm gonna ask the leader to step
in because you have you asked there were
two parts to your question
thank you thank you chairman i'm
grateful to mr swain for his question of
course
motions are presented to council in the
terms that the mover of it in this case
a councillor uh
sets out um the council is not
responsible
for whatever consultations a council
will make in uh preparing their motion
in this case they're quite right
chairman it would have been more correct
if i had said in the reply the notice of
motion will be considered later in the
meeting
the routine for the cancer is normally
to refer motion to further consideration
it may or may not be debated later in
the meeting i'm grateful to you for that
clarification thank you chairman okay
thank you councillor swain if i may just
comment it it is uh it is quite
important that talc
takes a role particularly in these
difficult times mr swain i thank you
very much to leave your input thank you
so if you could now remove yourself from
the meeting please sir and and then you
can watch us live on youtube okay thank
you very much thank you for your time
everybody it's a pleasure
are you able to confirm sarah that uh
both mr swain and mr ray have removed
themselves now
from the meeting
uh yes they have and uh officers will
put them back in the waiting room so
okay thank you thank you for that so so
moving on now to
uh
members questions countless questions um
the first question was from councillor
patch this was uh regarding his point of
order and i've responded to that but
you've received response today
presumably councillor patch
uh i have um received that response
thank you chair um i know with interest
you say it's regarding my point of order
i was not actually allowed to raise a
point of order at the last meeting
uh so do you have a supplementary
question counselor um i do not it's not
a matter that i want to take forward at
this time thank you chair okay thank you
very much indeed for that thank you
counselor doors as asked
two questions
three questions sorry cancel the doors
so the first country's question is
regarding land
decoy and you received a response from
the executive member for planning
would you like to ask a supplementary
yes i would thank you
thanks for the answer and thanks for
confirming that the the council paid
over twice the market rate for land that
would be allocated into the local plan
uh the question is are tdc happy for the
residents to make up their own minds
why the council was uh spending uh
taxpayer funds on land that would be
allocated in into the local plan without
any uh justification to do so
answered would you like to actually
respond no or provide a written response
thank you uh uh chair yes i'd be uh
happy to respond
um i think uh
councillor dawes hasn't uh read the
answer uh correctly uh certainly uh
the the land was uh slightly above the
going rates for uh agricultural land at
the time but i think uh council of doors
is failing to take into account the
position
of the land in relation to relation to
the town centre and also hope value that
might be attached to to such land as it
happens
the price paid represented a fair market
value for the land based on objective
valuation
it was
somewhere in the region of ten thousand
pounds it was ten thousand pounds an
acre that was that was paid uh which was
a sum that um
that land values did achieve in december
2014
uh
since then of course land values have
dropped for agricultural land
however team bridge have sold the land
back to the original seller
at a at a higher rate than was paid for
back in 2010
but in the meantime having secured it uh
for
either
uh
uh
employment land or for uh other other
land uh that may be required i think at
one stage
we were looking perhaps to consider the
land for us for a use for a school
um
it's now most likely to return to um
employment uh purposes but also to
uh to a to a part partially for use for
the for the link road which is a subject
i know close to
a council adores his heart
in terms of whether the public should
decide whether it's whether it's a fair
price or not um i think actually what
counts for doors is
is is uh is putting forward is is a
reasonable question i guess but uh but
at the end of the day uh the the price
paid is what was uh is what was
considered a fair market value uh
at the time and certainly you know any
any website on land values would would
show that it was what was reasonable
thank you councillor taylor so council
council second question was regarding
langford bridge and you've had a
response from the leader
would you like to ask a supplementary
counselor doors
the second question was about uh
ghost objectives yeah that's correct yes
yeah uh so that was the actual title of
the question
um
i'm pleased with the answer that it's
become a matter of public record that
the council is withholding
uh the identities of the objectors uh
i'm sure lots of counselors are
wondering why
i'm persisting with this point and i'm
certain that a small number of people
know very well why we're persisting with
this
and if the council refuses to
continue to
if it continues to withhold uh the
identities we'll have to take of the
roots to
uh to
find that information it is something
that any objector would have as a matter
of public record on the website so it is
totally unreasonable for the council to
do so but thank you for making that a
matter of public record
sorry so with the leader like to respond
thank you chairman i'm looking at the
achievements website now with regard to
the page which says speaking planning
committee
what do i do if i wish to speak up
planning committee and hear the words if
you wish to speak at a planning
committee please email an email address
by 12 noon two working days before the
meeting giving your full name email
address mobile phone number and quoting
the planning reference if more than one
person request to speak your email
address will be sent to all those who
wish to speak uh for you to arrange a
spokesperson between yourselves so
chairman i think um reading counselor
daw's question uh there may be a
misapplication in that he says uh
objectives are told that their details
will be a public record of course people
who object to a planning application or
one thing people who wish to speak at a
planning committee meeting or another um
we have asked uh councillor dawes
because he's previously said he's taken
legal advice or has advice
from others which says the council is
wrong and we said if you wish to share
that with us the council will reevaluate
the decision that's being made um as far
as i understand that advice has never
been shared with us
so i i say to mr dawes a counselor tools
my apologies i say to counselor doors if
you have that advice and you would like
to share it please do
if you want to pursue the matter outside
of the council because you think uh
we're wrong then then you must do that
but we set up our understanding as we
believe the law applies thank you
chairman
thank you leader uh councillor george
your third question um started the
planning advisory service invest in
investigation into langford bridge
um do you have a supplementary
the executive member of planning has
responded
yes yes i do have a supplementary uh
in in terms of uh
the
steps that have been taken in in the
influence of the interest of
transparency that uh
i'm let's believe this council holds
dear to its heart
uh can you explain to the members of the
public and the residents what steps have
been taken and continuously
explain
how it has addressed the serious
concerns that we raised as the planning
advisory service report suggested it
should do
five of which they didn't address the
council needed to reassure itself that
they have been dealt with we as members
are not reassured i don't think that the
residents will be reassured either you
can hide behind this report and you can
say it's long since it's been dealt with
but i assume you this is something that
will not be forgotten forgotten so uh
i'm afraid the council needs to do a
little bit better on transparency
thank you councillor doors so counselor
taylor would you like to respond no or
in writing
happy to respond uh now chair thank you
very much uh yes uh
i again uh council doors uh
he he he frames his questions in a way
that's uh that
that demands a response quite frankly uh
the
there is there is in his uh
uh question he talks of failings there
there aren't failings but there are
certainly been have been recommendations
by the planning advisory service uh
which could lead to improvements and
those improvements that will be sought
at planning planning
through the planning committee uh
shortly um
certainly uh you know as a public
speaker myself in the past i have had uh
some frustrations with regard to where
uh where a number of speakers wish to
attend if you if you're the first person
to to phone
to phone uh the uh and say i want to
make a
um
want to
speak at a planning committee then
you're not
you may not be told at that time that if
other people
details may be passed on so what tends
to happen is that
uh it's only when the second or third
person
uh
calls then they
may be told that their details may be
shared but i'm not so sure that uh that
the details are passed on for the first
speaker so i think there i think there
are some improvements that can be made
these are certainly been
[Music]
looked at by the planning advisory
service and i look forward to
any
changes that we feel that we can make to
the process
um
during uh
when the matter comes before the
planning committees but but in terms of
the planning advisory service report it
was as i said a previous council meeting
i believe it was a fair report there
were certainly some uh areas where the
planning advisory service didn't feel
that they could
take the matter forward
but
uh in terms of this matter in terms of
people public speaking at uh
at uh planning applications um i i
believe there are some improvements that
perhaps could be made and look forward
to
those
working out in through duke process
thank you great if you could tell the
rest thank you thank you councillor
taylor so no item seven on on the
financial on the agenda is the financial
plan proposals 2021 to 2022 to 2023 to
24. i'm asking the executive member for
corporate services to present
the item
thank you mr chairman
colleagues
can i first pay tribute to our staff who
have contributed to the savings made
especially our chief financial officer
martin flincroft and his team
colleagues we're here to consider a
recommendation from the executive in
relation to the final financial plan
proposals
2021
to 23 24.
i therefore propose that
a
that the teen bridge band d council tax
for 2021 2022 is increased by 2.85
percent
or 5 pound to
180 pounds and 17 pence per annum
b
the general reserves are increased to 13
of the net revenue budget for 2021 2022
or just under 2 million pounds
that 100 000 of the general reserve
balance
in any one year continues to be
available to the executive to meet
unexpected expenditure in addition to
the agreed revenue budget
d
all other decisions with regard to
budgetary changes will be approved by
reference to environment rules in the
financial instructions
e that the summary revenue budget for
2021
22
is 15.3 million pounds as shown in
appendix 4
in particular the revenue budget
includes
assumption of a 1.5 pay increase
first of april 2021
revenue contributions to fund capital
are suspended in the medium term to
protect the revenue budget
rural aid is suspended 2021
and 2021-22
the council's community grant is
maintained at 1 000 pounds each
f
that fees and charges are approved as
shown summarized in appendix six
this includes an increase in parking
income
of 94 000
from last year's base
budget g
that the capital program is shown in
appendix seven is approved in particular
this includes
increasing jobs and homes through
continuing support
for housing while backing business and
encouraging community-led planning
work has begun on the team bridge 100
affordable
housing projects at two sites in newton
a rent
rented program across urban and rural
sites will be delivered over the next
three years
increased investment for climate change
projects
including grant bids for low carbon
heating and energy systems improvements
at leisure sites and further provision
for the
carbon action plan
infrastructure delivery plan investment
contributing to improved education
transport links sports and open spaces
regeneration investment includes two
hotels in timmouth and newton abbott
funded mainly from prudent boring
the council recently received and in
principle funding offer from the
government's
future high streets fund
for a grant of 9.2 million aimed at
improving town centres
this will have a positive impact on
newton abbott and the wider team bridge
economy
co-funding includes sill
and grants from other sources and
prudent borrowing
this is also a provision for employment
sites invested
to be funded through the prudent
borrowing again
the future high street and employment
sites projects are indicative at this
stage
business cases will be brought to
members for consideration once they have
been finalized
that the prudent indicators are noted
and the prudent limits approved all set
out in appendix 10.
i
that the updated treasury management
strategy
statement and authorized lending list as
set out in appendix 11 is approved
together with the capital strategy and
appendix 11.
jay that each scheme will be considered
on its merits as explained at the end of
the appendix 11
to decide the calculation of minimum
revenue provision for capital
expenditure in 2021 22.
k that the treasury management mid-year
review of 2020 and 2021 are taken to the
executive on the 11th of february and
shown an appendix 12 is noted
el that the council tax
council tax re resolutions as
recommended in appendix 15 are approved
and colleagues in addition we are
recommending that we do not proceed with
this year's cost of living increase for
members allowance
so with your agreement
they will be frozen until april 2022
colleagues
this is a budget to promote social and
economic recovery and balance the books
on the 4th of february we received a
final settlement from government and
there are no material changes between
the provisional settlement i shared with
you on the 14th of january at full
council and the final settlement
the new homes bonus
a new round of allocations were
announced in the settlement year 11.
these allocations are one-off and will
not affect future legacy payments
in fact the written statement underlines
that this will be the final set of
allocations under this current approach
ministers are keen to replace new homes
bonus and plan to consult shortly on its
future
there was also no guarantees i'm given
that the local government funding reform
we are not guaranteed
sorry apologies we are not still we are
still expecting the reforms to be
implemented in 2022 23 but the
government's written statement only
commits to re visit the priorities for
finance reform in time for the next
spring
spending review
ministers will also be taking into
account the wider work on the future
of business rates
final budget proposals are to date from
the latest lockdown
no significant changes apart from the
budget gap widening next year
to 1.2 million
so moving forward
we expect next year will be balanced by
earmarked reserves a budget gap of 1.2
million
in 22 to 23
and 2.6 million in 23 to 24.
so over
the three years we have a budget gap of
3.8 million pounds
program is unchanged but slightly
rescheduling changes of dates
we will also continue to consider
whether we can reinstate the 0.5 million
revenue contribution from the reserves
to capital and we'll keep this as an
option
we now have the data back from our
survey on the budget
and we have resounding
support for the key areas
two-thirds of those respondents agreed
to increase council tax backing business
and improving town centers
71 agreed that we should invest in our
infrastructure
61 agreed to our proposals to support
housing and approximately two-thirds
agreed to our carbon management plans
in terms of looking at our future
budgets we have also had the following
responses
seventy percent of respondents agreed to
identifying
and generating more income to reinvest
in our council services
forty five percent of respondents want
us to look at making more savings
colleagues
our budget aims to reduce the impact we
have made on climate change
and revitalize the areas that which have
been hit the hardest by kovid
we are making some small increases to
fees like car parking and by increasing
the band d
council tax by five pound a year
whilst we only receive nine pence in the
pound of this money
colleagues our judicial savings from
previous years have meant that we've
been able to minimize the impact of
covid and the reduction in our grants
and income
on our residents
whilst making good our commitment to
jobs homes and environment
we need to make sure that we are
securing the best value for money making
the right decisions and prioritizing the
right things for the majority of our
residents and especially for those most
vulnerable communities
this i believe we have done
mr chairman
this administration through challenging
times has produced a budget for the
residents of team bridge bringing
forward our three main priorities
jobs
2 million for employment sites an
investment in newton abbott's high
street creating local jobs
housing
team bridge first 100 houses being built
now and creating local jobs
environment
our commitment to the climate emergency
employing a climate change officer and
our green leaf capital investments
colleagues working together across all
political groups we can and will take
team bridge into a green recovery and a
sustainable place to work and live
thank you mr chairman
thank you cancer keeling um you you've
actually proposed that we the the final
financial plan could i ask for a second
please
certainly chairman i second and we'll uh
reserve my right to speak later thank
you thank you very much indeed
just to confirm that's as per um the
report plus the additional
recommendation um regarding the freezing
of members allowances
i just wanted to be clear so the rest of
the members are now
thank you chairman um
yes i just wanted to comment briefly on
the
extra provision which has been put in um
by the leader um which i'd understood
was going to be put as amendment but it
is appears to be that's just going to be
included in a substantive vote for the
budget um regarding the freezing of
members allowances
um i just i like to make a comment that
um those counsellors who are not
receiving extra allowances for
positions on the executive or as leader
as committee chairs or vice chairs do
not receive a particularly sort of large
allowance for the time that they put
into um their their counsellor duties um
and just just want to put this in the
context of what's happened over the last
year in terms of the the executive
creating extra positions that attract um
substantial allowances an extra chair up
for an extra ons committee
for a lib dem member a vice chair
position which is uh attracts extra
allowances i believe
the creation of a without portfolio
executive position for a conservative
member these all add substantially to
their budgetary costs for members
allowances um and and it just strikes me
as this putting on this freezing of
members allowances is sort of it gives
the appearance of to gesture politics in
the run-up to the election and um in the
context of the
sort of reasonably small allowances that
members not with extra allowances get
then i wonder if a more appropriate
gesture might be for the leader
to maybe freeze his for the executive
members to freeze their allowances or
perhaps chairs all of those receiving
extra allowances and not to freeze the
allowances of those members who do not
receive these extra allowances um
at the same time i mean perhaps that the
leader can give us an indication of what
is the extra allowance that he receives
so i would imagine not freezing that
freezing that would not have such an
impact as not freezing um
ordinary members with no extra
responsibilities allowances
chairman i'm quite happy to clarify all
all members allowances special
responsibility and basic would be frozen
so everyone will be affected thank you
chairman thank you
councillor kolcloff
yeah thank you chairman um
you know i go along with the budget and
i understand times are hard but i can't
uh
forego this opportunity to express my
disappointment and concern that rural
aid has
been suspended again for another year
uh i think this is uh
a penalization on rural areas will
depend very much on a very small amount
from team bridges budget which does such
good work in rural areas and there is a
disappointment that this has had to be
foregone again i'm just hoping that next
year this will be brought back and
looked at more favorably and the system
might uh come into being again for rural
areas which depends so much on on such a
small amount from timbridge's budget
which does such good work and good pr
for
team bridge
in rural areas thank you chairman
thank you councillor would you like to
yes please do yes abs absolutely because
when we first thank you mr chairman and
thank you councillor kochloff for
raising this issue you know when this
first came out i i was also in the same
position as yourself
but you know we've had some hard
decisions to make
um
as you're aware there are other grants
available to community halls our
communities
and most i know have applied for
you know the the covid grants and the
these are quite uh you know ten thousand
pounds grant which is sometimes three
times that precept
and certainly a lot more than the rural
aid grants uh gave out so
there is a case there that some parish
councils um have have benefited greatly
um from
other grants that are are available um
you know
also you know where where where do we go
here you know we've had to save those
areas that we
considered were very important and like
the cab the citizens of ice bureau that
is a very important uh
uh
area that supports you know those people
more vulnerable those those people that
need that help and we we've continued
that support uh that's not been
decreased but i'm afraid we've had to
make a decision on the rural aid grant
to freeze it again this year so um i'm
sorry council called club hard decisions
made we're we're in difficult place at
the moment
thank you councillor keeling uh
councillor eden
so i was
failing to find find the right the right
button and i i will be supporting um
i will be supporting this budget but i
want to make a very a really important
point about the future of politics which
is this it's interesting that we refer
to our allowances and what district
councillors get paid all that allowances
and if we look at the demographics and
the people who are counsellors we can
see that most people are using these not
as
something to live on but as something to
you know
as a bit of an extra which is why it's
an allowance and this is wrong we're
never going to get the kind of
representation we actually need in
politics if the only people that can
afford to be counsellors are either
retired or working part-time and that's
i think we should be brave in the future
and say if we actually want better
representation we want to see people in
the chamber in their 20s oh shock horror
you know people who've got young
families and people who are just you
know struggling struggling to to to get
the bills paid if we're not going to
have people
you know in the real world representing
themselves while we have this kind of
19th century model of giving giving a
golf club membership to the people who
take part so i want to see real
strategic change to come thank you thank
you councillor eden councillor rolison
thank you chair just also on the
subject of councillors allowances um
i don't receive any additional
allowances i just get the basic ordinary
allowance it's it's quite sufficient and
i think all members should be showing
some kind of leadership in these very
difficult times
because many people are suffering great
hardship and the last and it's an honor
to be elected it really amazed me that
people put so much trust into me
and i don't want to take money when
others have been denied so much i'm
making so many sacrifices and working so
hard to keep this uh coronavirus at bay
so
i think it's absolutely right that that
we don't take an uh any addition at this
time and and otherwise i will be
supporting this uh this budget as well
thank you chairman thank you councillor
rollerson councillor boulevant
i'd just like to register the fact that
we'll make will be making a formal
response
on behalf of my group to the budget if
you caught me at the appropriate time
thank you thank you
councillor hawking
yeah thank you uh mr chairman
um
just take your hand out there you go
that's better
although
i'm gonna vote for this budget um
because i feel there's no other way
around
this this item that we've got now we are
we are in a difficult situation and one
that we never thought we would be in
this time last year
um so i will i will vote for this budget
my problem is that
there's a lot of um a lot of words put
on the recommendations here um which
actually to me say nothing
and it does concern me that we're being
waffled and we're being confused by
words being put onto
being put onto this budget that actually
really does not say anything um the
regeneration of newtonia now um 10
councillors had an update um just a few
days ago
on the future high street bid
and to be fair it did not go down very
well um
i can see i appreciate why tdc wants to
push that bit forward um
but they're in my res in my own opinion
they're using that bid to
finance um
a regeneration of their own property
which was due for regeneration which was
always coming to us as a regeneration
plan and they can they see this is a way
forward of financing that without
actually um financing it through our own
coppers uh and i think that is a worry
because i think they're pushing through
certainly the queen street part of it um
and i will be bringing this up when it
comes back to us again but i think the
queen street part of the project which
is the part that is actually pushing
the uh future future high street part of
the of the grant um i feel that that
is never going to work and i don't
believe that what this administration
has put forward for this budget is
actually going to help jobs
um
but that as i say this is my own opinion
going back going on to the um
members allowance uh i have been a
member now team british district council
since 1998.
i was working at the time
um i did not believe that although i was
always accepted the allowance i was
going i did not believe that
i was entitled to as much as i was
getting um
because
for me i became a counselor because i
wanted to be a hamster i wanted to do
something for my community and i saw it
as a way i didn't see it as a way of
making money or or whatever um so
therefore i i'm quite happy to see this
this allowance being frozen this year um
i'm quite happy to see it being further
for two or three years to be quite
honest because i think that what what
we're getting is way above what we
should be getting we should this this
allowance should be to
to um
to give us money back for time that we
put into it
for
um papers and whatever we buy
my biggest expense now since we've been
since corporate started has been on the
on broadband um everything comes through
on email email um therefore my biggest
expense is broadband and
phone calls possibly
so
to me i'm quite happy to accept that
part
the resolution on appendix 515
um to do with the council tax summary
now i have read this two or three times
this morning since i've had it
and i am more confused now since i read
it than what i was before
um i really don't understand what it's
telling me whether i'm a bit silly or
what i don't know but i really do not
understand what it's telling me
having said all that
i can i can see no option but for us to
support this budget um i may not i don't
think it's the best budget in the world
i don't think it's been written the best
way in the world um but we are where we
are and therefore we have to set a
budget
and unfortunately this is the only one
in front of us well thank you
thank you council council
i i need to apologize because i should
have invited you to speak earlier
um because of my i have old technology
and i tend to cut and staple and i think
i've put a staple through that bit so
i'm really really sorry so please go
ahead
thank you
your apology wasn't necessary but uh
appreciate what you're doing
um
when we look at this budget obviously
i'm looking at this budget as an
opposition uh group
and it is our duty as an opposition to
hold the executive to account
firstly
i think everybody in this council
recognizes the challenges that the
council officers face in producing a
balanced revenue budget in these
uncertain times
but this has been done as a great credit
to the officers involved with this
budget presentation
as i say as an opposition party is our
duty to critically analyze the proposals
contained within the budget identify
areas where the policies of the
controlling party fail to deliver the
best results for the residents of teen
bridge
but we are also pleased that the
executive have acknowledged the the
previous administration
[Music]
has placed this council in a better
position to face the challenges than it
would otherwise have been but even so on
this basis we identify some major
problems with the budget they come from
a misguided series of policies being
implemented blindly
by this administration contributing to
the almost four million black hole in
the account we see in the years 2022 and
2023
this budget contains major multi-million
pound decisions that are based on a lack
of financial and commercial awareness
investments propose there are double the
cost of equivalent options readily
available and has uncosted
administration and running costs and
ongoing procrastination in investment
programs
it has also withdrawn plans to provide
some of the local improvements already
funded by developer contributions
and cut the support to supporting our
local economy
and for this reasons this budget fails
the residents of team bridge
the basic lack of understanding by the
executive has resulted in proposals that
hurt the poorest in our communities
does little to help build prosperity in
our communities and spends the money of
our council taxpayers unwisely
the areas of concern are clear
we all want to help those in most need
this is not a party political issue it
is a statement of fact
this administration has declared the
wish to re-enter the housing supply
market by setting itself up as a
competitor to the same housing
associations that took over team which
is housing stock some 12 years ago
that decision was made by the same
people who are making this decision now
the lack of details are of great concern
no details of running costs nor of
additional administration
nor the principles to be applied to
social rents have been given
the plans included have the first
developments taking place in new habit
where the town center sites are included
free of charge
yet the build costs are in excess of 214
000 pounds per unit a true cost of over
300 000 per unit that is double the
price of equivalent units currently
available nearby from housing
associations
we wish to provide homes at social rents
to those who cannot afford the current
affordable rents is laudable and has our
support
provided we know the principles
governing how those tenants are to be
chosen monitored and supported we
endorse the concept
however the decisions must be in must
ensure that any investment is made
wisely
so the question is what would we do
differently firstly
we would not be spending one and a half
million on building units who could buy
at half the price
we would not be spending upfront the
equivalent of a hundred year social rent
discount for property
we would not set ourselves up in
competition with housing associations
we would sell the two sites currently
planned and therefore generate an
additional half a million pounds from
the sale of the land we would buy the
same number of equivalent properties on
behalf of housing associations loss of
loss avoiding the costs of administering
expensive administration
the one and a half one quarter million
savings made and the balance of
projected investment would be invested
to support local high street businesses
to convert their upper vacant space into
homes to letters social rents bringing
life back to the high streets supporting
local businesses and providing homes for
over 200 families across all areas of
teen bridge
doubling our commitment to social
housing and we would partner with
housing associations to do this
this will be a conservative control
administration policy that delivers not
only for newt nebbert but for timothy
and all the other towns and parishes of
team bridge
secondly
through our housing policy there are
over 250 vacant building plots available
across team bridge waiting for self-will
to custom build the buyers
we will create a joint
company with local builders to serve and
service providers to construct homes for
local people to buy
designed to high standards and to meet
any special needs that families have and
contribute towards reducing the housing
waiting list
this will also provide employment for
local businesses and generate a
financial return for the council
thirdly we also see that the budget
includes spending over 1.8 million per
year on computer services obvious 400
000 pounds is spent on naming streets
and looking after documents
we would bring these tasks in-house and
save at least 200 000 pounds per year on
the comparison with other
similar authorities we'd expect to save
a further quarter of a million pounds
and together that would give a saving of
450 000 pounds a year
fourth
at a time of climate change we
acknowledge the need for all car uh
council decisions
to be made respecting the drive towards
reducing our carbon footprint
we believe our highly qualified and
experienced officers can meet this
challenge they will cease spending on
the department overseeing their actions
and expect office of professionalism to
deliver a saving of a hundred thousand
pounds per year
fifth
as we emerge from the unparalleled
trauma of the
uh kobe pandemic it is imperative that
we work to help our residents economy
and local businesses recover
as soon as possible
to this end we believe that there are a
number of projects that have been
delayed for a number of years that
should be accelerated to deliver
immunities to local communities and
provide work for as many local companies
as possible
the health and well-being of dawlish
residents will be improved by the
expansion of dordish leisure center a
project that has been on hold for over
three years
similarly we'd push ahead with the
redevelopment of teamwork
leisure center to benefit uh tim with
residents
we will use local businesses to improve
the children's play areas that have been
waiting for the last two years for
improvements repairs and upgrades
we would seek a development partner to
develop the centre of newton habit so
the required improvements are in place
as soon as practically possible
all the things are highlighted are
deliverable within the budget numbers
presented without additional borrowing
or increasing the projected liabilities
of the council
the one thing we would not change is the
investment in communications it's an
important service that team bridge
provides residents that we are pleased
that after objecting to this expenditure
each year over the last years whilst in
opposition the lib dems now recognize
the value of this function have added an
additional hundred thousand pounds to
their budget
in conclusion
our budget would be built on a belief
that the in the people and future of
team bridge it will deliver the support
to those who need it help more people
into quality homes improve employment
make team bridge a better place to live
and work
for those reasons we will not
support the budget we will abstain from
voting on that budget thank you
thank you councillor boulevant
councillor dawes
thank you
a couple of points actually i'd just
like to agree with councillor eden who
uh
who notes that there's baked in in
inequalities in terms of representation
and and if other members are are quite
happy and and don't need the funds then
what a lucky position we all happen to
be in that that isn't what a democracy
should be based on those who can afford
to uh to stand um
i don't say on the executive uh i
haven't formulated the budget
uh i haven't drilled down into the
detail as much as i would i haven't done
alternative modeling so i'd be
upstanding on this but i i also
recognize the amount of work that must
have gone into this and it is without
doubt a a wartime budget um
one thing that i did ask at the ons
committee when we looked at this is
relating to the property portfolio that
the council owns bought by the last
administration and when we were elected
councillors uh the officers were telling
us with pride what a wonderful return he
was getting one or two percent more than
if the money was sat in the bank i'd
imagine that the the level of risk
around that investment is huge now
so like many other councils team bridge
has invested in property portfolios that
will not be receiving rent that do not
hold the value that will have to have
different uses in the future so uh what
i would hope to see is a great change in
mindset and a change in direction and
strategy in terms of how that property
portfolio is dealt with we have an
opportunity we have an opportunity to do
something different we have an
opportunity to look at the housing
prices which indeed is lesser housing
prices more an affordability crisis and
build the houses that we actually need i
i
i was laughing at uh
councillor bulovan's uh
some suggestions of what the
conservatives might do differently if
they were in power given the destruction
of newton abbott as a small market town
uh filling the pockets of the
doors please you you're straying into a
territory which is rather unpleasant
uh i'm i'm talking about the uh the uh
development that's been done around
newton abbott which is pertains to
uh
the the policies that this council holds
so i think it's reasonable that i can uh
like councillor bulovan hold this
council to account for for is the
terminology you were using counselor
doors about lining pockets that's
unpleasant
okay well i think i think it's a fairly
national uh uh
policy that chamocracy rather than
democracy uh is is in play and we've
seen that work what i would do is urge
the executive uh to change course uh
we're in an emergency we're in two
emergencies now uh one of them we've
seen great action uh done at great haste
we require a handbrake turn not nuancing
and i would urge the
uh executive to take great and and
effective action in terms of
readdressing the local plan and the
sites that he allocates to build houses
on thank you thank you councillor dawes
councillor dewhorst
thank you chair um so so i listened to
the leader of the conservative party uh
on cambridge with incredulity um
he was talking about developers uh who
who we know have profited greatly from
the last
eight years uh development across team
bridge and uh i'm supporting this
particular budget uh because it it it
takes away from that uh and and gives
proper housing to local people at
affordable prices rental property that
is so desperately needed
in in our community
he also mentioned strata which is quite
interesting really because
strata was
an organization set up uh by the
conservative
administration and
for the first time uh
this administration has actually managed
to put a break
on some of the expenditures made by
strata
and in fact councillor wrigley uh will
be introducing um later on in this this
meeting uh about that very issue uh and
how we we for instance managed to um to
to make quite a considerable saving um
in uh in in the future plans for that
but of course to come out of strata and
uh and and change everything
would cost this council dearly uh
because the conservatives were happy
to
to chain us to to the other two councils
i'm also supporting this budget because
of the increased in
investment in climate change
and low carbon heating uh i think um we
we have many issues at the moment but
there is no
greater issue truly no greater issue
than the future of our planet
and we must um we we really must be
supporting that and then finally um this
may not be the best budget in the entire
world um but i think it is the best
budget uh possible for the people of
team bridge and that's why i'm
supporting it thank you chad thank you
guys
council mcgregor
thank you chair um
it just just it it does make me uh
chuckle somewhat when i when i hear
council obvious um
you know response to the budget
um i don't think any of our residents
will be conned into believing that uh
his response is anything other than the
developers charter
and it's about producing more and more
houses across the district at high
profit levels for developers and
landowners
i think it's um it's it's rich that he
should also be
attacking the executive for not getting
the leisure centers upgraded
when the um
when the
administration came into to power in may
2019 there was actually at that stage no
plan for refurbishment of the two
leisure centers other than a very basic
outline plan
that was due to come into
the executive for consideration in 2020
however as we know the kovid crisis took
that element out of our hands
and until we see
um
how the recovery will take
um on terms of fees and and income for
the for the leisure centers it's very
hard to plan ahead on how much and how
extensive the redevelopment of both
daulish and and uh
newton abbott and
broadmeadow would actually would
actually happen so i think it's it's
it's very very easy to make wild
promises about how they would do this
and how they would do that the reality
of the situation i mentioned last year
that we have to cut our cloth to fit
and unfortunately last year we did cut
our cloth to fit and then we had the
pockets ripped out along with the lining
by kovid so we're now in a situation um
where we do have to very very carefully
manage the finances going forward and i
believe that this budget is a good
example of that and it's a real um
you know commendable effort by officers
and also uh councillor keeling to get
this budget into a format that actually
delivers for the residents now not for
developers but for residents
i think it's really important to
remember that all the way along
um
we've seen the conservatives push push
push for developers and even the even
coming to the strata point that council
boulevard made about naming streets if
the conservatives had their way we'd
have many many many more streets and
probably higher cost again
because of their housing policies that
are inflicted upon this district
so uh with that in mind i think i will
be supporting the budget um and i think
it's a very commendable budget but just
to come to one point uh was made by
councillor doors
i think we are making really really good
progress on the
climate change emergency in the
ecological emergency that we're declared
the unfortunate thing is it'd be nice to
be able to do a handbrake turn but that
costs a map some money that we really
really do not have and cannot divert
otherwise residents interests would be
harmed in the short term um thank you
very much for that thank you councillor
mcgregor councillor jackie hook
thank you chad um yeah i will be
supporting this budget i'd just like to
make a few comments on items that have
been raised um firstly um on the future
high street um fund bid that we were
successful in winning 9.2 million pound
for investing in newton abbott town
center um
obviously i welcome this i'm quite
incredulous that no one would welcome
this um with open arms um and just to go
over um
you know the process obviously all
elements of the future high street
scheme went to public consultation and
and had a good level of support from the
public and the people of our town and
surrounding areas um the um
the components of the future high street
scheme fund including the queen street
bit but all components of it um have
come from a long process of consultation
with the people of newton nava maya
firstly their community plan which was
put together in 2008 which then fed
shortly after that into newton abbott's
own neighborhood plan
um the town council's own neighborhood
plan so this isn't um a set of whims
that um
somebody's put together within the last
couple of years this has come from a
long process of public consultation with
the people of newton abba
um
and
just to remind some of the elements of
the new habit neighborhood plan included
um looking at changing the priorities of
traffic in queen street i think those
are the exact words from the
neighborhood plan
improving cycling and walking green in
the town center and improve in the
evening economy so exactly as has been
asked by the people of newton now but
thankfully now we have the opportunity
to deliver on that and i'm really really
pleased and i think the officers
involved with that did um a really
really good piece of work and um thank
you from the people of newton avenue um
secondly on
the east street housing um site that was
mentioned by council of bullard of
course we need to remember that the
conservatives sat on this vacant site
for i've forgotten how many years but
certainly when i became a councillor in
2011 it was vacant then and all through
the rest of their administration they
sat on a vacant site and failed to bring
forward any scheme or sell it off or do
anything with them and within a short
period of time we are now building
social rent low carbon houses on that
site the first social right houses since
the 1990s we are not doing that in
competition with the housing association
we are doing that in partnership with
the housing association who will manage
those properties and future properties
that we bring forward at the social rent
um
so i'm going to be supporting this
budget i wasn't quite sure whether
council of relevant
he was right to say that we should trust
in our officers um delivering on climate
change because i do know there is a big
commitment amongst our officers and
senior leadership team on climate change
and i thank them for that but was he
suggesting that we get rid of the
climate change officer i didn't quite
pick up on that um to me that would be
absolutely absurd we have the most
amazing climate change officer who has
really transformed the speed at which
we've been able to address the issue in
the council
we wouldn't be bringing forward a really
ambitious carbon action plan in the next
month or so if it hadn't been for
william elliot and i thank him very much
and um his job is safe in our
administration
um so um yes i will be supporting this
budget because it reflects the livedown
priorities that were in our manifesto um
genuinely affordable housing addressing
the climate emergency and of course
we've added in the ecological emergency
since then and
um creating jobs so i'll be supporting
them thank you thank you councillor
councillor keeling
um
mr chairman i i'd like to let a few of
the counselors have a a word in if i can
come in after
maybe uh councillor wrigley and
councillor jeffries
um
and councillor clarence as well i'd like
to hear from him because he normally has
something to say on the budget when i
thought he was sidelined a little bit
yeah okay
thank you so councillor clarence
uh thank you chairman yeah um i'd like
to bring it back to the real
nitty-gritty of it
which is the revenue budget i mean it's
a big sums of money that this council
deal with isn't it
the forecast for 21
22 is 62
million 100 000 pounds
big sum of money that's what we get in
and that's what we propose to spend
and
you know it does interest me with these
big sums of money when the strategic
place services
including uh economy and planning
has gone up from 7.1
million uh spending
in the 2021 forecast
to uh
it's anticipating that the forecast as
i've said in this 21 22 year will be 9.2
million
that's an increase
in that budget there of 1.9 million
pounds this is famous and then we talk
about getting
rid of a small diminished amount
like um counselor mary colcut was
looking at the the sort of loss of the
rural aid
i i think you could lose that
rural aid straight away in that 1.9
million pounds
um
you know i'd i'd like to
you know you could have just reduced
that by
whisker really and still kept the the
rural aid
and you know we we
that's 1.9 million pounds extra that can
anticipate spending in that budget and
then we look at shall we say the
specific grants
mainly housing benefit
the 2021 forecast there
was that we were getting in 27.2 million
and spending 28.2 million and this has
been always the case for years and years
that um
we have to administer this and that's
why it's always been a net loss of the
figures that i've just quoted of a
million pounds now suddenly this year in
cowboy yeah
it's a net gain to us this year
in
in coming up what's ahead of us in the
21 22 forecast
we're due to uh getting and
26.9 million
and only spend 26.2 million so suddenly
with 700 000 pounds to the better
apparently we've received a grant and
that grant money's gone into that to
make it look uh uh improve our finances
uh so we're seven hundred thousand
pounds better there so all i was making
the point was in context
you know it seems rather uh when you get
these very small amounts of money
that that
impact badly on on rural
parishes that such as mary kolkov was
elaborating on
why we need to be what i call it seems
so
frugal in these amounts when you
actually look at the budget forecast
it's been very difficult this year and
to cross reference
the the spending and what have you
because you can't sit down with officers
and say exactly what's this and what's
that and you've only got an ipad to work
off unless you you're privileged enough
to have a super duper computer where you
can put pop it on one screen and try and
save it and print it off and cross
reference it all so i
that's the reason that i haven't spoken
more in depth on this budget
but uh that's all i've really got to say
that it seems a bit
frugal really when
you've got these huge sums of money
involved that you can just tweet a
budget somewhere and not lose something
that is dear to us thank you chairman
thank you councillor clarence councillor
wrigley
thank you chair um i'd just like to
address some of the points that
councillor bulevant brought up which
shows a misunderstanding not only of how
housing works of how housing
associations work how the housing market
works and how pushing money at
developers simply causes everything to
be more expensive
team bridge 100 is set up to deliver
extra new homes for team bridge
residents at social rent
how those homes are allocated will be
debated that's part of the devon home
choice and part of the housing uh
policies that will come up later so
they'll be clearly uh that's clearly
there and as set out
team bridge 100 is using existing plots
of team bridge land initially
to actually develop areas that haven't
been developed for a long long while as
count as my
as the former housing portfolio i'm a
holder my colleague jackie hook pointed
out
the first two sites going forward have
been available to progress for many
years and his
uh previous administration which i
believe he was a member of the executive
in fact indeed communities i think he
was didn't actually push this forward at
all
so the idea of selling such plot of land
to developers at a profit and then using
it to reinvest just simply didn't happen
and is mythical
so he's making things up now that they
weren't doing when they had an
opportunity
if one did manage to sell such a plot of
land and give them money to actually
purchase more section 106 housing the
limited stock of which we get from
developers who like to maximize their
profits by building on greenfield sites
as opposed to these sites which are
brownfield redevelopments
then what would that do would that
actually get more affordable housing no
it would simply put more money in the
pot for the housing associations to bid
for that housing they bid against each
other it's the way the government has
set up the system so that would simply
put the prices to the developers up
it would simply put more money in the
developers pockets
i think it has been said before and i'll
reiterate it councillor bullevant likes
the developers paradise and would act
everything through that route
in this project we are working very
closely with the housing associations
with registered providers
i have been meeting with each of them
working out how we can work with them
and help them to deliver more housing as
well as us delivering more housing
team bridge 100 is unique in this
council's experience in the last 30
years it is delivering new council homes
it is delivering an extra supply of
housing
we have some 4 000 households on our
needs list
four thousand
every year we sorry i beg your pardon
one thousand
every year we
house about 400 households at the end of
the year we still have a thousand
households needing housing
team bridge 100 will start to modestly
reduce that number we need extra homes
not just more of the same not just more
privatization not just more developers
paradise i'm proud to stand behind team
bridge 100 it is a pipeline of
opportunity of homes for people in this
area and will return
a
it will wash its face in council terms
it will not cost this council money
it will be
pretty much neutral a small return
but it will be more homes for local
residents
and i'm proud to support this budget
thank you councillor wrigley councillor
jeffries
thank you chair
um
some of my colleagues have um addressed
the issue
um the future high street fund in
relation to the budget with housing so i
won't go into any details on that but i
just wanted to say that i'm really
disappointed actually um
at the beginning of the meeting the
chaplain opened it to
ask us to put aside our political
differences and yet the response to the
budget from the leader of the
conservatives was to put forward an
election manifesto um
i will be supporting this budget because
i think it's something that's critical
for the recovery of the area
um and it's a budget that's mindful of
the times that we live in and what the
community requirements are and that's
really all i have to say so thank you
thank you councillor jefferies
councillor keeling
thank you mr chairman thank you if i can
address council bulletin's um
impromptu got together
um
proposals
what the residents of team bridge during
this pandemic want us
from all sides from every group on the
council is to work together
council boulevard is being pure
political in bringing these proposals at
this late stage mr chairman can i remind
the leader of the conservative group
that the budget has been one of the most
highly consulted on documents
starting back in october november time
when the leader of this council council
anaconic gave weekly friday briefings
including this budget to a briefing you
know i i gave a briefing to this on the
full council on the 14th of january i've
done two town and parish council
meetings which were packed
four overview and scrutiny meetings of
which
you know council boulevard is a chairman
of that
and he came up with no questions
you know
no questions at all
and and now i i i question has he
consulted with his group because if that
is the case why did the deputy leader
you know the council of clarence
second a motion of support of this at
overview and scrutiny one
we have also completed a team bridge
wide six-week public consultation
which supported the budget
you know
i'm just
hard to believe that you know we got
public backing
but there will be no scrutiny of council
boulevard's proposal by the public here
and now
mr chairman you know
this reminds me of a saying my father
would have said
you know it seems like you've made this
up on the back of a packet of cigarettes
in your break time
you know
i i just
so late in the day
no no
no working together from councillor
boulevant in his his group by the sounds
of it and they're going to abstain on
something they voted for all the way
through this process um i i i finished
with that thank you very much mr chair
thank you councillor keeling uh the next
blue hand is canceled iconic would you
like to wait until the end counselor
call it to sum up
i would share thank you much thank you
so council of bulavant
uh thank you i recognize the uh
the uh opinions of my uh colleagues um
i find it interesting that highlighting
a wish
to spend more that is necessary
that that's criticized i recognize that
the fact that the resources can deliver
far more than his plan
is ignored
the fact it's about putting people into
homes that is the reason behind our
policies
is not appreciated by the opposition uh
by the uh
by the members of the executive
that um
the failure to consider the best value
for money the best returns for the
people of this um
of our
area
are the ones that just get no
credibility from the executive
whatsoever all they're interested in is
their own um
dogma
um i have nothing to say
i think it's uh interesting some of the
responses that we've received i'll leave
it up to uh council comic now to make
the response thank you councillor
william
councillor clarence
thank you chairman i think um with
respect to councillor killing he's got
his wise cross i didn't vote
at ons one for that i left the meeting
before before i had had somewhere to go
and i tried to get on their own on this
two to start in the afternoon to put in
my budget things told that i had to go
on to uh youtube and listen to it and
couldn't speak uh
at the afternoon meeting so i i didn't
uh do as councillor keeming suggested
and voted for it
thank you
clarence thank
you councillor mcgregor
thanks jeff for the the second
opportunity i i just
you know want to kind of follow up on a
point made by councillor councillor
jefferies i mean what what's been
presented today um by council bullerman
is actually a manifesto and it is
slightly disingenuous of councillor
bulovan to present it in such a way as
to say that we are guilty of dogma what
we are guilty of
perhaps is
wishing too much to try and please
everybody all of the time and i think
actually what we've got here is a budget
that deals mostly with the residents
needs and is aimed firmly at making
things easier for residents yes we've
had to put up some parking charges yes
we've had to put up council debt but at
the end of the day without those we
would not be able to meet our service
commitments to the residents as well and
i think it's really important to to note
that this council has sent um
information to mps to suggest that we
expect to make further losses as a
result of the lockdown that we're in
currently
even though it will start to ease soon
it still will impact on income across
all of the district areas in devon and i
think it's really really disingenuous of
uh council bulletin to start committing
funds
that we don't have that we might not
even get either and i think for for
somebody to
um you know suggest that we are dogmatic
is is pretty laughable under the
circumstances when we know that the
dogma from uh the conservative party is
to focus on conservative billionaires
making millions of millions and billions
of pounds through developments and
blighting many districts with over
development thank you
thank you councillor mcgregor so two two
more counters wishing to speak cancel
the doors and then i'm going to ask
councillor connick to sum up so come to
the doors
thank you
yeah i just wanted to to come back on
the
uh the process because i'm also confused
by uh the conservatives position now
because i sat on ons two and this was
debated uh and i grew a lot of derision
for for my position of abstaining on
ons2 i was a singular voice
and i'll remain consistent for the
reasons why i'd do that but at that
point and the proper
point in the process overview and
scrutiny would have been to scrutinize
it and i know i don't have any
recollection of any of the points that
were raised
uh earlier in this in this debate were
raised at ons two so it does appear to
be pure political theater and posturing
and something that i'd be very very
disappointed with if uh if i was a voter
thank you thank you councillor so
councillor connor as the leader would
you like to sum up please
you're muted uh leader
so i don't done that sorry thank you
chairman um can i um start by thanking
all colleagues for
let me ask you a good debate um on a
number of issues
but before i go into my reply i do
i'm probably on behalf of all
councillors i want to extend our
greatest thanks to all members of staff
at team bridge
for their work right through the way the
pandemic in the past year
uh the big crews the refuse crews our
street cleaners literally all the way
through to the managing director uh
because we've kept the show on the road
and i hope all colleagues will just take
a moment to reflect on that that our
staff have kept going kept going to work
and that has been
not just tremendous from our customers
point of view but i think it's been
tremendous from what they've done and
particularly in recent weeks when many
of our staff would have been home
schooling their children as well as
turning to and doing reports and
whatever else needs to be done for the
council so um my thanks to all of them
chairman
uh in response into the budget uh i
will probably just ask you you don't
need to look at it now i'll give you the
figures but on page 47 of the budget
pack is probably the most telling it's
appendix 6 and you'll see that the
actual income for the council last year
2019 20 was 10.1 million pounds and the
probable for this year 2020-21
is in round term six and a half million
um we are four four-ish million down
three and a half million four million
down
that's a telling tale uh for anyone to
just sober their thoughts on
the impact of the pandemic because the
council while it relies on cancer tax
income has done over many years now what
government has asked us to do
is to be inventive to be entrepreneurial
to look for other sources of income
which is what we've done
and we rely on that income and what the
past year has shown us is that when you
get something like this all be unique in
100 years um
it really has affected our income so
this budget which i had hoped would be
something that was cross council and
withdrawal support
um
without some of the political theater
that we've perhaps seen in the past uh
40 minutes or so um would be a truly a
budget for teamwork so can i start by
thanking colleagues um
for
uh their support where they've given it
uh and i particularly actually know what
council door said he did abstain and he
is quite right he drew some rice smiles
when he abstained in uh overview
scrutiny i attended both meetings and he
is also right to say that the
opportunity for the conservatives to
have tested their ideas to ask for
changes
were given up they simply said nothing
at all
uh i am surprised by councillor berlin
or perhaps i shouldn't be um but
equally as councillor patches pointed
out in order to reach out across the
council uh this isn't a holy lib dam
executive we invited uh councillor percy
to join the executive and councillor
persa has supported the budget that's
been prepared and has been recommended
to council
so i addressed these short remarks to
members of the conservative group
through your chair which is simply this
if you are genuinely abstaining then you
need to reflect on what you're saying to
the people of team bridge if you're
genuinely abstaining having foregone all
opportunities for the council's process
to make the best budget possible that
you could have delivered today
however
if like some of your colleagues you've
believed that this is in the
circumstances the best budget
deliverable then please vote for it and
show that party politics need not be the
division between us but actually maybe
the thing that unites us in these times
of challenge and adversity when our
public need us most
chairman then into uh some of the
matters that have been raised um
mary colclough expresses disappointment
with regard to the rural aid suspension
i appreciate that
but also this is a budget which
maintains support for the citizens of
vice bureau for the council for
voluntary service
and colleagues will recall that when the
pandemic started in the first lockdown
we were swift in our aid to help food
banks and other organizations get off
the ground and provide support across
the council
our age and our support for our
community is in my views second to none
it is a
it is a reflection on all of us as
cancers all 47 of us that our first
thoughts were for the community and
continue to be
so far as i know we are the only council
in devon and probably the south west
which maintains and continues to
maintain 100 council tax support for
those in greatest need other councils
expect even the poorest to make some
contribution but it's not without cost
to the council we are maintaining it no
one is going near it we want to support
our people
and we know they're hurting because we
see the numbers of universal credit
applicants rising we see the amount of
free school meals rising there is
poverty across team which not all of us
may necessarily recognize or see that
this budget supports our communities as
best we can
or trying to find time and space to
balance our books over the next couple
of years
mike hoggins says well a 9.2 million uh
was it just a bid to support our assets
well
it links in a bit to a question that
counselor doors raised about the
purchase of the market board shopping
center chairman i support the purchase
of a market walk shopping center it was
the right thing to do this wasn't part
of some splurge of cash to buy shopping
centres left right and center it was a
strategic purchase because we owned one
part of the town center
and the market walk came up it was
previously owned by a large finance
company an insurance company i recall
for whom nittany was just something in
their portfolio
for us the newton albert shopping center
is the thing in the portfolio
and richard dawes is right it does need
uh and did need modernization but that
insurance company was never going to do
it it was the council that has invested
and it's a council that would invest
again so i say to councillor hocking
would you prefer 9.2 million spent on
an asset owned by an insurance company
or an asset owned by the people of team
bridge for the people of team rich
delivering for the people of team bridge
that's what we're about delivering for
the people and i say to you mike
please think again we're investing in
newton abbott
the choice is do we get the 9.2 million
from government or do we not and if we
get it we're investing in our turn
and the market has changed covert has
changed and in the past we were told
that our units in the market walk
shopping center weren't big enough to
attract the big retailers maybe as the
mists of covid clear and we can see the
way forward much better maybe our retail
units will be the right size maybe
they'll be the place that they want to
go hopefully we're going to get more
independent shoppers and shop retailers
into our stores let's work on that basis
rather than any other
counselor currents
again perhaps shows himself
not to fully understand the budget
because he talked about the housing
benefit let me just say within there
because the increases of money he refers
to includes for example the 1.9 million
kobe provision against income losses it
provides it includes the extra grants
that we've had from government towards
covid and in terms of
the communications budget which um
councillor bulevant referred to again
that refers to some
stuff changes changes in the way staff
or allocated implied within is not an
additional 100 000 pounds for that
service but reflects the way the service
has been changed to benef to better meet
the demands
of the council
chairman
we
believe and have three primary
objectives to deliver housing for people
to deliver jobs for people
and to
do what we can in our small way but
actually in a big way
tackle climate change those are our
three objectives and this budget
continues that support
now i understand where phil bullock is
coming from he's a conservative and he
wants to peddle that particular
mythology to everyone it's not anything
i'm going to have any truck with
i grew up in a council house others of
you may have as well
and i would firmly go back to a system
of modern council housing
and managed by councils where people
knew where they were and in times of
difficulty uh could get rent rebates and
the system looked after itself and i
regret
that the council houses were ever sold
off the fuel pull event is wrong
it's wrong to say it was the democrats
that sold them the liberal democrats
signed the contract the actual decision
was made by
conservatives uh prior
to the actual event uh in the actual
transfer and councillor russell was
among those who voted for it and i doubt
this at some time previously at an
earlier counselling some time ago
so it's always helpful just to recognize
that the conservatives have achieved
their ambition is selling off the
council's stock in football and i said
well why didn't the liberal democrats
vote against him well by that time the
council had already spent two and a half
million percent in his ambition of
selling the council's stock it would
have been a complete waste of money but
then as phil bollivan describes today
he is quite keen to waste council money
chairman let me then just move to where
we're at now
this budget does many things
all focused on supporting the people of
team bridge
i appreciate that in this budget there
will be some things that people aren't
keen on there'll be some things that
they actually don't like
but most of it they may like
i think there's a lot in here for the
people of tingbridge it's an ambitious
budget in the circumstances the one that
invests in cambridge it is about jobs it
is about the economy it is about housing
is about climate change i need make no
apology to anyone for the things that we
are doing in this budget we are all
swimming against the tide in a very
difficult circumstance
i really do employ all of you to vote
for this budget i particularly and
especially appeal to those conservatives
though i know that this budget is the
right one in the circumstances to vote
for it don't sit on the sidelines and be
a footnote in history this budget this
budget more than any other i've been on
this council is the one that delivers
for the people of team bridge and i
encourage all members to say they are in
favor thank you chairman
thank you leader
members the final financial plan
proposal for 2021 22 23 24 has been
proposed and seconded just before we go
to the vote i need to read out a short
statement in accordance with the local
authority's standing orders england
amendment
regulation 2 of 2014 a roll call will be
taken so can we go have a roll call
please beth and go to the vote please
members
answer austin
councillor bradford
stein
[Music]
councillor comets
counselor david cox
or
cancer hugh cox
councillor doors
abstaining
cancer
evans
four
councillor foden
oh cancer goodman bradbury
for
cancer gribble
abstain
councillor haynes
cancer haze
council hocking
abstract
can't say gordon hook four
councillor jackie hook
ball
counter jeffrey
cancer jefferies
councillor jenks
cancer keeling
cancer care as
well four i'm sorry a today
councillor mcgregor
four
cancer morgan
oh
cancer malone
for
cancer natalie or
cancer nuttel
councillor
oh
parker khan
cancer patch
or
cancer pit
council linda pedreck
council persa
or councillor rolison
or
councillor russell
councillor swain
four
cancer taylor
council thorne
that's the team
abstain
councillor wrigley
oh
cancer parker
thank you very much indeed and i think
that moves us nicely into a comfort
break now i make it 10 to 12.
so if everybody can go
before we go i
i'm sorry but i put my hand up but after
coaching spoke coach iconic used my name
and i believe and no that he
misinterpreted what i said and it would
have been nice i was able to to come
back and explain exactly what i said in
respect of the regeneration of newton
abbott and the future high street fund
um but obviously that's now gone by but
i just like it noted that what i what i
said and what council connect thought i
said was not correct thank you okay
thanks thank you councillor and
apologies if that was an oversight on my
part so as i said members a comfort
break now until 12 o'clock so a 10
minute comfort break before you go if
you could switch off your your camera
and also your microphone please
thanks john
so
so
hmm
chair at 12 o'clock we'll need to do
another roll call to confirm that
everyone's come back into the meeting
absolutely yes
beth could you carry out a roll call
please
counselor austin
council austin
councillor bradford
president
councillor bill event
council clarence president
cancer colclough present
cancer connect
present
cancer david cox
cancer david cox
cancer hugh cox
cancer doors
yes i'm here
cancer dewhurst
present
cancer eden present
cancer evans
present
cancer foden
presents
cancer goodman bradbury
present
cancer gribble
present
cancer haynes
present and i can see that when
councillor austin tried to say president
kept muting so she's there obviously on
the screen thank you councillor haynes
councillor hayes
president
cancer hocking
yeah president but i'm gonna have to
leave about half past them
cancer gordon hook present
cancer jackie hook
counselor jeffrey
cancer jeffries
present
mcgregor
present
captain morgan
council malone
president
councillor nutsley
councillor nettle
present
councillor
president
cancer rolison
president
councillor russell
cancer swain
present
cancer taylor
present
cancer thorne
present
cancer
present
cancer wrigley
present
cancer parker
present
counselor john petherick president
thank you for that beth
as i mentioned earlier members um i
thought it uh appropriate to move two of
the item items on the agenda forward so
the next item on the agenda has been
moved forward from 15 and that's a
constitutional working group update from
the leader of the council
thank you chairman
so chairman encounters
the constitutional working group met on
wednesday last week
the cwg comprises the four group leaders
and councillor keeling and during that
meeting councillor patch kindly attended
and spoke to the matters he has
identified him as a notice and motion to
council today
speaking personally i believe that the
november 2020 updated constitution
reflects a task set by councilman's
decision of september 2019
but looking ahead what has become clear
is that the council does not have a
mechanism and probably hasn't for some
years really which enables cancers to
have oversight of the constitution its
procedural arrangements cancer training
and development and for instance initial
receipt of the report from the
independent remuneration panel
reflecting on all of that
all members of the constitutional
working group agreed this should be
addressed through the creation of a new
committee
with councillors agreement today terms
of reference and proposals for
membership will be brought back to the
next council meeting for consideration
and so chairman just as a few words by
way of recommendation to kind of
formalize what i've just said
i would invite council support
for a new committee being established
oversight of the council's constitution
procedural arrangements cancer training
and development reports on the council's
independent remuneration panel
terms of reference and membership
details along with any other relevant
matters to be reported to the next
meeting of council chairman i'm quite a
secondary for that
thank you
i'm happy to second that
council event seconded
i think this is very welcome actually
that we need to do that i'm afraid our
old constitution had in fact
contradicted itself and had become
totally out of date with the with law
changes and uh we were um
slightly uh
negligent as members in not keeping our
constitution up to date and and legal uh
i would hope that the and i'm really
pleased that we've got this new
committee i would hope that this
committee would look
very much of redressing the balance
where we have where we the members and
yourself as chairman is the guardian of
the constitution and that we uh we seek
to take ownership of it as as as
councillors and i hope we can do that
but this is the mechanism to do it and
i'm very pleased and very much welcome
this this committee being formed uh
but so i would certainly support that
thank you very much indeed councillor
connect
just just by my reply um
if around the speakers i'll speak at the
end before
um the recommendations considered
chairman
uh there aren't any other speakers
thank you very much i'm grateful for
what david cox has said of course i
should say the council does have a legal
constitution always has uh so um
without sort of trying to open that
debate because i know we obviously got
motions later on uh the new committee
would be an appropriate place and i
think that's what david cox was
endorsing thank you chairman
leader would you mind sort of stating
exactly what the um what sorry what the
agenda item is please or sorry certainly
so john to
so the recommendation is that a new
committee is established to have
oversight of the council's constitution
procedural arrangements
and development
reports from the council's independent
remuneration panel
terms of reference and membership
details along with any other relevant
matches to be reported to the next
council meeting
thank you councillor dawes
thank you um i'd i'd agree uh
with uh
councillor cox's uh point on this that
is key very important
i'd like the
terms of reference of the group to be
very
wide and over overarching in terms of
membership and involvement and
i'd also like which probably comes to
the motion later that uh i do believe
the constitution has been changed
uh without due process and i'd like us
to be operating under the previously
agreed constitution until that point
uh but we'll debate that motion
hopefully uh shortly but uh but i would
agree that
there needs to be full oversight by
members of any changes that happen to
the constitution doing otherwise would
be an abuse of power
thank you councillor doors councillor
eden
thanks yes just a couple of clarifying
questions um council comment mentioned
procedural arrangements well i just
wondered what what those what an example
of those
would be in terms of things that would
be taken to this constitutional
committee and would they include
anything to do with standards
oh and the second one
was he said the word he said relevant
and i was wondering if um i was
wondering if you could give me an
example of what he meant by relevant you
know what what relevant looks like
relevant in the sense that
the constitutional working group may not
have captured everything so it was terms
of reference and membership details
and any other relevant matters to be
reported as in anything relevant in the
setting up of a new committee um
so
you know i i don't know because the
point was if at some point in a few days
time someone thought of something i
didn't want the commit the motion to be
so restrictive that was oh no committee
you can't slowly agree to change the
reference and membership details not to
you know i don't know whether you might
take advice from any outside
organization or whatever you know so it
was a
it was an idea
we would come back to the council with a
recommendation
in the process of that procedures
is about the way that so as constitution
is the rulebook procedures might be
about the way the council operates um
and
again it was to try and sort of give
the membership uh a place where
oversight could be so
chairman if i could speak to what
council doors said of course members can
attend any committee they may not be on
it but they can attend and speak at the
moment constitutional working group
meets on an ad hoc fashion a committee
would meet because it's diarised in the
council's calendar meetings uh with
proper sort of papers and all the rest
of it so all members would see it and
would be able to engage if they so wish
chen
thank you leader thank you can we go to
the
councillor eden you've indicated you
want to speak again
yes sorry so i was just trying to
understand about whether this committee
would be having as part of it it's remit
and what it would be discussing are the
the behavior and processes of other
committees
such as standards
um i can't answer that because we need
to come back to council with
terms of reference so this is not about
what i think but
i'm gonna have to do some work with
officers and come back so
i think i'm being asked the question i
can't immediately answer okay no that's
fine thank you
thank you
so no more blue hands so can we go to
the vote on this note please beth
councillor austin
councillor bradford
paul
cancer bullet or
david cox
councillor hugh cox
councillor doors
poor
cancer dewhurst
or
cancer eden
oh it shouldn't be sorry answer eden
councillor evans
paul
councillor foden
fool
cancer goodman bradbury
oh
cancer gribble
four
cancer haines
cancer haze
cancer hocking
or
cancer gordon hook poor
cancer jackie hook
oh
cancer jeffrey
cancer jeffries
or
cancer jenks
or
cancer keeling
or
cancer care as well
or
cancer mcgregor
or
cancer morgan
cancer malone oh
counselor natalie or
councillor nettle
for
counsellor orm
or
cancer parker khan
or
councillor patch
or
council spain four
councillor taylor
councillor thorne
four
councillor team
four
councillor wrigley
paul
council parker four
councillor john pedreck
jack can i just check uh councillor
austin
um i didn't hear your vote on this i
couldn't hear it
[Music]
and can i just
check council eden you were voting for
were you i saw you but i couldn't quite
hear you
sorry
yeah
yeah thank you
so um yeah that's being carried
unanimous thank you okay thank you sarah
so the next agenda item is item 16 which
i've decided to to move up the agenda
and it's notices of motion
notices of motion shall be referred to
the appropriate committee meeting the
mover of the motion can outline the
proposal and then it will stand
adjourned the motion may be debated to
assist debate later if agreed by
two-thirds of the council members
so there are three notices of motion for
us to consider today the first one is
from councillor egan
regarding uh
sorry standard committee process changes
that she would like us to
consider
so counseloring would you like to
present your notes in motion please yes
thanks very much and hello everybody um
so i i really would like to hear
colleagues opinions on this motion to
improve standards processes today
if however the vote um to debate that
did fail to get its two-thirds i i would
like now to propose that the um my
motion is referred to the new
constitutional committee outlined by
council connect just now
rather than back to standards for
reasons that i hope will come come clear
so um
i'm going to make a couple of remarks to
try and persuade councillors to discuss
my very specific recommendations and
because it really would help me evolve
them if i could hear what people thought
about them i i'm assuming that people
have had a chance to read in detail what
i sent through
so i would say that it is a truth
universally acknowledged that
communication is very difficult
misunderstandings are common and
language is an extremely slippery
servant of truth
and at a time when you know looking
around the chamber um we can see that
the council is is by no means
representative of the demographics of
its wards i think it's imperative that
we make a real fanfare of modernizing
our standards and processes and making
them fit for purpose and professional
and i've become aware actually recently
of a couple of working women who don't
want to be counsellors unless there's a
change to the way and culture in which
we operate
now the standards committee changes i
outline in the notice of motion
are about process and they're about
accountability
and they introduce ways to safeguard
against human error in reporting and
minute taking and i'm going to take two
specific points
it's a unique feature of the standards
process for councillors that it has the
potential to ruin careers incomes and
minutes
and futures outside their their roles as
councillors yet unlike in a legal
setting not only is it not possible ever
to question or appeal a standards
decision it's not even possible to point
out any errors any any typos even and
any simple inconsistencies in the
written communications made public from
the chair's office even when those iris
and and infilicities are potentially
damaging a councillor's future and
income and i have plenty of examples
that i can give people separate to now
secondly of my two there are often
several months between the publishing of
draft minutes which may be incorrect
maybe in maybe defamatory may as
mentioned earlier be full of accidental
typos and slip ups um and many months
after they've gone online sometimes the
standards committee may meet to approve
or amend them
so obviously in that in the time that
elapses there are questionable maybe
questionable content being published
and finally on a on a personal note
having chaired many nhs research ethics
committees i know firsthand how
difficult it is to summarize often
complex discussions and report decisions
now we would never publish draft minutes
of decisions that affect individuals
lives without
editorial processes and scrutiny of
approval discussion and checking
and on that basis i move i plead with
you all actually that the motion be
debated today and i seek support from
colleagues let's let's modernize this
council let's make being a councillor
more appealing to working people and
make our processes stronger in the
process thank you thank you councillor
eden just to be clear
in your notice of motion you were
specific that you wanted it to go to the
executive if we decided not to debate it
today but no your preference would be
the constitution working group when that
is formed is that correct yes i think so
if i've understood correctly what alan
just said that seems like the perfect
place that's fine so members
thank you so members you need to decide
now whether you want to debate this
debate today or not
if you want to debate it please when we
go to the vote vote for
if you don't wish to debate it then
please vote against
can we go to the vote please
cancel austin
or
cancer bradford paul
councillor bullavent
against
cancer clarence against
cancer colclough
for
cancer connect
against cancer david cox
again did she go to the constitutional
committee
council hugh cox
against
cancer doors
or
cancer jew herst against
cancer eden
four
councillor evans
against
cancer foden
against
cancer government bradbury against
cancer gribble okay
cancer haines
against
cancer hayes
engaged
cancer hocking
or
cancer gordon hook abstain
counselor jackie hack
counselor jeffrey
cancer jeffries
council jenks
against
cancer keeling
against
council carswell
against
council mcgregor
captain morgan
against
captain malone
oh
council on that today gaines
council nettle
against
engaged
against
council russell yes
councillor swain against
councillor taylor
against
councillor thorne
against
councillor team
against
councillor wrigley against
council parker
against
cancer john petterick against
chair two-thirds did not vote to debate
the uh motion today
okay so so um councillor eden's motion
will be referred to the new constitution
working group when it's set up then
the next uh notice of motion is from
councillor gordon hook uh would you like
to present your notice of motion council
hook
thank you chair
uh chairman and uh and colleagues
you have the noticed emotion it's it's
not lengthy in wordage it's uh clear i
think hopefully concise
and i'm assuming everybody's ready but
if not i'm very happy to read it or get
the chairman ask the chairman to read it
again but
um
in anticipating that you've already can
i can i say that i sincerely hope that
um
everyone in the room will join with me
in in in thanking without reservation
the numerous volunteers who giving
freely of their time and energy devote
themselves to making life better for so
many people
right now we are all well aware i'm sure
the outstanding work being undertaken
day in and day out by significant
numbers of local residents to help
neighbours
friends
complete strangers
in the difficult uh coronavirus
dominated times we're living through
many would have suffered immeasurably
more without the self-sacrifice of local
volunteers
volunteering has come to the fore with
the cv epidemic and it is absolutely
right in my opinion to acknowledge the
help being given
i believe authority in the form of the
local authority can and should recognize
and and thus support and encourage this
activity
i know those doing voluntary work don't
don't do it for recognition or praise
but nevertheless it is right
for us to
consider ways in which we as the local
authority
can work more closely and perhaps even
more cooperatively with this vital
sector
i say uh even more because i am aware of
areas in which we do work together
this is acknowledged
but let's engage with the sector and
listen to their needs
they are playing a vital role in
community welfare and cohesion
and surely this is not only
a good thing
but it is to be recognized and
encouraged
i would like us to for instance
an award of some sort
for outstanding service in the sector
this could be explored by ons
i have in mind maybe a certificate
acknowledging the council's
uh gratitude and to to those who are
giving this outstanding service and
maybe the chairman of the council would
occasionally hold a little soiree or a
little um
event whereby
he or she uh
as circumstances dictated would would
make a presentation and acknowledge the
this this work i think there is merit in
in considering that
as just one idea
i don't wish to confine our thanks
uh or
collaboration simply to those who have
come forward at this specific time
however to help with the uh cv
consequences
volunteering has gone on long before
cb19 struck and will be going on well
after this plague is conquered
a huge range of positive activities have
always been organized by volunteers
it could be the local wi the children's
sports clubs
cubs scouts guy whatever 101 different
possibilities of really great
selfless work going on
uh we need to encourage even more
proactively with with the sector insofar
as we are able
to promote and assist with the
challenges that modern day living
produces
in my opinion it is more likely than not
that the voluntary charitable sector
will have an increased role in the years
to come as community activity
re-establishes itself
we need to be proactive and supportive
in that evolving situation
i really hope that we can come together
across the chamber
in this instance at least to simply
agree that this is an idea worth
progressing
but that we can share ideas as to how we
might achieve
i don't claim to be the possessor of all
good ideas far from it and there's a lot
of people here who've got lots of good
ideas to share and i think that if we
could just come together with a with a
meeting of interested parties
and listen
we could learn
and make real progress in this area
thank you mr chairman i hope there's
agreement
thank you council look am i right in
understanding council hook that you're
not asking the members to debate this to
today you're happy for it to go straight
to executive i'm happy for it to go
anywhere as long as it makes progress
ultimately and i certainly not bothered
about it being discussed today
in that case then i i think we can just
note that members that it will go to the
executive
council volume do you want to comment on
this notice of motion
i'm very happy to go to executive
if total
with my total support and if
an application came in towards ons for
one of the committees to look at this i
then again endorse that as a way forward
thank you i i don't think we need to
vote on this because the the mover of
the motion has requested it go straight
to the executive uh councillor natalie
thank you chair yes i mean i totally
agree with with that side of things but
i would just like to say that um
counselor parker khan and myself i've
been very involved in in ashburton we
formed a group when the cove had started
i myself have been doing the
administration for the what we call
lockdown larder food bank
um we had 283 volunteers come forward at
the very beginning of this
um
and i'll say it's been a community
effort right the way through uh for the
whole part what almost a year now um i
was fortunate to be able to get a 1600
pound grant for the for the food bank um
and we've been given other money as well
but to say pedro parker khan and i have
been on this committee ever since the
kind of start of it and uh fully support
this notice of motion by chesterhook
thank you
thank you councillor i wasn't actually
expecting many members actually to
comment on this so um consider warn
your beauty cancer or
you're still muted
okay can you hear me can you hear me
yeah i just wanted to say that um we've
been doing something very similar for
many years in terms recognizing the
wonderful work that our volunteers have
done for our community and then we have
an annual event apart from obviously the
year of um coronavirus where we
recognize those very people and bring
them together and um it might be worth
just taking a look at what we've been
doing here in timmus
thank you councillor councillor wrigley
uh thank you chad i was just going to
say as a portfolio holder for
communities working with voluntary
sectors
comes under my portfolio and i'm very
happy to take this forward into
executive and if members would like to
uh email me with ideas and thoughts and
input to this i'm very happy to take
that into consideration thank you
councillor wrigley councillor kurzweil
thank you chairman um yes in bobby tracy
we've been doing this thing for many
years
um with very good response and the
people that have actually
received awards throughout the years
have been
really delighted and it's boosted morale
tremendously
um i i would like to think that we could
do the same at team bridge it's a very
um
interesting task having watched the
process over the years
and
a very difficult decision to make in all
honesty when you get so many really good
people who have been nominated
um it's very difficult to choose
thank you
thank you councillor kurzweil
so that the council of hooks um notice a
motion will be passed to the executive
for their consideration
uh the third notice of motion is from
councillor patch
sorry um
just to clarify councillor edens notice
the motion um will have to go firstly to
um executive and then be referred to the
new committee because we haven't joined
that yet but you know we can put that on
the next executive to be referred to the
new committee and then when the terms
are referenced so
hopefully
all members
understand the process
thank you sarah thank you
so councillor patch would you like to
present your notice to motion please
thank you very much chairman and um
thank you also for recognizing the
importance of constitutional issues
and um bumping up the agenda the cwg
report and the notices of motion i'd
also like to thank the leader and vcwg
for putting forward the proposal a
successful proposal to put together a
new committee to explore constitution
and related issues
moving to my
notice of motion
my starting point
is the constitutional provision that the
full council is responsible for adopting
and changing the articles in the
constitution or rules of procedure and
um in the constitution of the full
council this also extends to and
includes
functions and schemes of delegation
sections of the constitution and
agreeing and or amending the terms of
reference for committees
now um sometime over the christmas
period or working on some council
business i noticed that um at some time
on or after the 20th of november last
year a new document purporting to be the
version of the new version of the
council's constitution appeared on the
council's website
this was a surprise to me as i'd not
seen anything come before um full
council in terms of agreeing or adopting
a new version of the constitution i do
concede that um in september 2019
delegated powers were given to the
monitoring officer to make some tidying
up and um bring some consistency to
various um provisions within the
constitution and across the constitution
however in in that paper um
a very specific
point was made that and i'm quoting here
from the paper that supported
the decision of september 2019 for the
avoidance of doubt and as indicated
above the existing rules will not be
materially changed
now
just um provisional exploration of this
of this new um version so-called of the
constitution has
actually unearthed the fact that there
are several apparent material changes
from the last adopted version of the
constitution
and these i'm just to summarize them
that i i've given six example points in
the notes of motion that was circulated
to councillors along with actually i i
gave an extract to the previous um
adopted constitution so that members in
preparation for this might be able to
compet compare specific articles between
the adopted version and the new version
that's appeared so just to quickly run
through those six points they are
what has changed
has degraded the rights of members of
this council to present questions to
full council
the rights of members of the public to
present questions to full council
the rights of members of this council to
present motions on notice to full
council
the remit of overview and scrutiny
committees has been changed
and the powers of overview and scrutiny
committees to require to require senior
officers and executive members to attend
and explain decisions actions and
performance and finally of these example
points the loss of power of group
leaders to veto delegated minor changes
to the constitution that might be to the
detriment of a member of the public or a
councillor now with regard to
some of those changes i'll just just
highlight one which was the power of the
um managing director to disallow
questions
um by members and and indeed of members
of the public um
this this specific
provision actually came before the
council at a previous point and was
referred back to the cwg
for further consideration but it then
subsequently appeared in this new
version of the constitution not only
that it has been used in the last
meeting of this council i put forward a
question for council and the managing
director used this new discretionary
power to actually refuse that question
to this council
that that's the
information set out in my notes of
motion
and and indeed as i pointed out i've
provided direct references to articles
in the new constitution and the previous
um relevant articles in the old
constitution
now um
my so my point being that um and this is
contrary to actually to my mind an
impression given to a member of public
who who asked a question regarding the
constitution this morning this new
version of the constitution has not been
submitted to council it's not been
scrutinized by council and has not been
agreed or adopted by council
given particularly those material
changes
now
at a previous council meeting we had a
very lively and well informed debate on
democracy in this nation and particular
um give giving some thought to the the
perceptions of the public and their
trust in
their democratically elected
representatives
i i would hope that given the
seriousness of these changes to the
constitution and seriousness of this
whole matter of integrity of the
constitution
members of this council will now vote to
debate this motion that i've presented
with a view to
actually sort of reinforcing the fact
that the last adopted version of this
council
of the constitution is not the version
currently on the website that that ought
to be reverted to and that future
material changes ought to be brought to
the council perhaps via this new
constitutional committee at the very
least i think this issue needs to be
debated not least because of of the
effect it has on the rights of the
members of the public to scrutinize this
council and the members indeed of this
council to scrutinize this council and
the apparent loss of powers to officers
to control the powers
of members of the public and members of
this council to scrutinize this council
i i see the way that members vote now on
whether to debate this as a touchstone
on their their views on local democracy
so i move the motion be put forward in
order to decide whether it may be
debated now
thank you thank you councillor patch uh
just to be clear um you you as with
councillor eden would your preference be
that it was considered if it doesn't get
debated today that it is considered by
the executive for forward and if we
moved on to the
constitutional working party would you
be in agreement with that
i think that that would be acceptable
that seems like a logical way to proceed
however because of the seriousness and
the fact that members rights and
privileges are currently um degraded
under this supposed new version of the
constitution i think it needs urgent
attention now
okay thank you for that so two
counsellors have indicated that they
wanted to speak about this to the park
chair chair before anybody speaks and
goes to debate we do need to go to the
two-thirds
we need to have the two-thirds if you
want anyone to speak on it okay
understood okay thank you for that so so
we need to go to the vote now members
and and if two-thirds of us decide that
we would like to debate it then we will
uh if you want to debate it today please
say four if you would prefer not to pay
today debate it today please vote
against
should we go to that please
counselor austin
councillor austin
councillor bradford
or
cancer relevant
cancer clarence
cancer cold cliff
cancer connect
yes
cancer david cox
it's an important issue that deserves
proper uh scrutiny and therefore i'd say
against let's get it to the
constitutional committee
councilor hugh cox
thanks
cancer doors
cancer dewhurst
you may have left the meeting chairman
cancer eden
cancer evans
against
cancer foden
against
cancer goodman bradbury
against
cancer
ripple
against
councillor haynes
against
cancer hayes
against
cancer hocking
[Music]
cancer gordon hook
counselor jackie hook
cancer jeffrey
councillor jefferies
council jenks
gates
councillor keeling
against
mcgregor
as with david cox against
councillor morgan against
cancer malone
oh counseling net today against
councillor nettle against
councillor
for
cancer parker khan
or
cancer patch or
cancer pete
engaged
council linda pedreck
against
councillor persa again
councillor rolison against
councillor russell against
cancer swain against
cancer taylor against
cancer thorne against
councillor team
against
councillor wrigley
generally with david cox against
councillor parker
same as david cox against
councillor john petherick against
chair two-thirds didn't vote to debate
it so it would be referred to executive
to be referred on to the uh new
committee okay thank you very much
indeed for that thank you
now revert back to the original running
order of the agenda item eight on the
agenda which is the recommendation from
the executive and it's timoth public
spaces protection order and that's going
to be introduced by
myself
sorry yes i was looking for a name sorry
apologies yeah
uh thank you chair
so we have before you today a public
spaces protection order for tinmath now
normally i am loath to put forward
public space protection orders because
they can be draconian
but in this case i think this has been
proven to be necessary and i think we
should go forward with this
this is about trying to
assist
in poor behavior particularly the
abuse and misuse of alcohol and other
substances
in and around the centre of tin muth
particularly or specifically the den the
seafront the back beach the triangle
wellington street and lower brook street
this has come forward through requests
from tinmath timoth town council and the
police in tinmouth
after numerous occasions where they had
anti-social behavior they had
great difficulties that has caused
concern to residents locally
the public spaces protection order has
been brought forward and my
the thanksgiving safeguarding and safety
and safeguarding manager who has worked
hard on this along with the rest of the
team
this order has come forward to give
powers to clamp down on the anti-social
behavior that the local residents in
tinmath are suffering
it has gone through a local consultation
in tinmath it has gone through timmouth
town council where i believe it was
supported unanimously
and i bring it forward to you now and
ask for your support in putting this
into place
thank you the post proposed by
councillor wrigley is there a secondary
please
seconded by council linda patrick thank
you
council linda patrick i see your blue
hand is raised is that inadvertent or
no i was going to make a comment on it
if that's okay fine
um just to say i support this
and the reason i support this is we had
a situation like this a couple years ago
in dualish and we had to do the same
thing
and
um although we didn't want to do it it
did actually make a big difference so
that's why i'm going to support it
thank you councillor president
councillor cox
yes mr chairman uh very much like
counselor pederick it is a regret that
we have to do this
there are particular problems in tinmuth
with a
and the police have requested this and i
think if you um
uh
accept the police in tim of those
sensible people and they will use it
appropriately but it's right i
also would add that the town council is
looking at ways that it can deal with um
uh putting money into youth services and
other services so that it's not just all
um
uh sort of all iron fist there's some
other alternative um proposals as well
to help uh deal with the issues um uh
and it will give the pcsos and the
police the powers to deal with things
and i hope and i think for the most part
our
local neighborhood policing team have
worked in ways that are sensible and are
not over over the draconian and i think
we'll use these powers wisely but it is
a sad regret that we've got to use them
but i think on on balance it's the right
thing to do i do hope that we would look
at also including the [ __ ] valley nature
reserve and we don't just move the
problem from the town centre to the barn
and the uh [ __ ] valley they just thing
but that will obviously be part of the
drawing up of it
thank you councillor cox councillor
russell
uh thank you chairman i would echo what
david has just said and i would also
include uh east cliff park in in in that
area because there is a lot of problems
there in that beautiful area as well um
can i say that um
it's not the regulars who are in the
triangle and the police know well and
and have a good relationship and talk to
them
it tends to be the useful element that
comes out late at night and and really
does cause problems because the triangle
is not only a commercial area but it's a
lot of people live above those shops and
flats there and um
it's very distressing for people to
have all this going on underneath their
windows night after night and i fully
support this
we all know what goes on and um
it's not everybody that does it
certainly uh
people who are in the triangle
who know regularly go there they're not
they're not the problem it's it's this
noisy element of youth and and also i
think that some drug use is involved in
that as well and um
the police do their best but they do
need uh extra support and this would
give that thank you chairman thank you
cancer russell councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um i'd like to
echo
councillor cox's comments as well and
obviously um point out that it is not
just the center of the the the town that
that's an issue there are there are
other locations there
outside the town centre that still
present a few problems
what i would say is um
perhaps part of the the escalation the
problem has been the fact that the
there has been a reduction in in police
resources over the last decade
around about 10 of
headcount lost and um as you know you
know they are fighting losing better and
we did see last year
with the uh
lockdown easing that there was a
significant increase in anti-social
behavior both on the back beach and on
the promenade and littering
and and some attempts were made by tim
the town council um to give them their
credit in in addressing that
particularly councillor andrew henderson
i think he's worth a mention in the
efforts that he made in in addressing
some of the anti-spiritual
behavior particularly around littering
cigarette ends
dog mess that sort of thing so i think
it's quite important
that we um facilitate
um improving that process and backing
the texture mechanism
thank you councillor mcgregor council
malone
hi yeah thank you it's um it's a little
bit depressing listening to people
you know um
adding to a list of places that they
don't they don't want young people to
congregate um i mean
young people at the moment uh you know
for the past year they've had their
freedom curtailed they've had their
liberty curtailed they've had everything
that they need to develop into
responsible citizens
curtailed uh you know they're going
through things that none of us ever had
to go through
living up
growing up and uh we're all sitting here
saying what a nuisance they are where we
should ban them from now if this is a
chronic problem
uh then i i think we should think about
the timing slightly and we should
discuss it when things have returned to
normal and we see if this alleviates
this problem doing it now
on the back of a year of youth clubs
being closed skate parks being closed
the young people can't meet at home it
just it looks anti-youth and and it
looks it looks so timed thank you thank
you councilman councillor wrigley
i was just hoping to sum up at the end
chair finally that's that's okay uh
councilman cox
so if i can just reassure councilman
it's not just young people some of some
of the people are in their 50s and 60s
and they are causing a nuisance because
they get drunk and they basically pass
out on the triangle and cause other sort
of problems for traders and the old
anti-drinking um
things have now been replaced so
effectively in some perspectives putting
back in place what it already existed
there is a hard core of and i do think
that probably mustn't be an
an anti-youth thing but the p the young
people of tinmuth are our credit to our
town i'm really pleased with them they
i've been involved with them where
they've done social action in clearing
up areas that needed clearing up and
they've helped to bring communities
together in victor's lane with their
work uh that was done under the auspices
of the town council you know it was
fantastic being on this 14 year i think
50 14 year olds turned 14 15 years
turned up and did stuff so certainly not
an anti-anti-young people thing and uh
councillor henderson has been mentioned
he's work he's gonna look to work with
um youth genesis to see if we can put
some more youth stuff in the town but
actually this is not just in the past
year this is two to three years in the
making this and it is really is the last
resort we have
regrettably had um
a stabbing and other issues where people
have come from other
parts of devon um to to sort of have a
ruck with some of the people and so it
is it is it is sad that it's come to
this and i it's not something i like and
i do take his point about vilifying
young people we must avoid that because
they say 99 of young people are good and
i mean councillor um
uh andrew mcgregor mentioned about um uh
about the
people on the beaches but let's look at
our recycling centers those aren't young
people who are dumping cardboard and
rubbish on there and they're no better
than people who litter on the beaches so
i think you know we're doing this the
older generation are as equally uh to
blame as as the youngsters but if
there's a particular problem in in
timbuk the police have said they need
this to do it
i trust them to do it sensibly and i
think for that reason we should support
it but i take the point about being
anti-youth but i think if you understand
the issues you will see this is not an
anti-youth um thing and we and the
townhouse is looking to put in more
things for young people
during lockdown and after lockdown
thank you councillor cox councillor
patch
thank you yard chair yeah i i would like
to initially echo um council malone's
points about the current situation and
um young people being bereft of
opportunities to lead um normal sort of
healthy um socially sort of well just so
social lives really um but my main
concern is that um
what's going to happen when this is
enforced will the problem just be
shifted to another area will we have um
other board members coming with um
requests for crackdowns and air areas i
think i would have liked to have seen
some kind of positive response in terms
of dealing with the issues that are
arising rather than just um sort of
resorting to
um
an approach which is likely to
unfortunately to sort of move the area
or move the issue onto another area um
just finally also um maybe i misheard
councillor david cox um i thought i
heard him refer to somebody working with
eugenicists but perhaps he could clarify
what he actually said
thank you councillor patch councillor
i'd really like to just reiterate what
and what council of cops said that it
isn't just an issue with young people it
does cover the whole spectrum of all age
groups and here in timothy has been an
ongoing issue it's not something that's
just been the last year it has been
going on for some time and we do trust
our local police to make sensible and
sensitive judgments when dealing with
anti-social elements and i would like to
also say that it's incredibly important
that we we help young people and we
support them now and in the future it's
been an absolutely dreadful year not
just for them for everybody but
particularly young people and there
isn't a great deal for them to do here
in timeless so um we really really do
need as an aside
to focus on the future for them and
support them and not just seem that
they're we're pushing them away and that
we're forcing them to go elsewhere or
that we
you know we think they're behaving in an
anti-social way because they certainly
don't all behave like that
um and we need to support our young
people
thank you councillor councillor swain
thank you chad um others have already
made my point really um so i'll be brief
but i want to welcome what council
malone said about young people and the
challenges that they face absolutely
agree with him and i think that's a very
constructive approach to it but as the
anti-social behavior champion um i'm
also very aware that our our team within
the council are very competent and
using a wide variety
of um initiatives to get the best that
they can from this issue which is quite
challenging and
i have confidence and support that team
in putting in place just one of the
tools that they need
thank you
thank you councillor swain
going to the comment
thank you chairman um
i think it's unfortunate that the start
of a conversation appeared to focus on
young people and
other colleagues have said um it's it's
not the proposed restriction is not age
limited it affects behavior it's not
about young people or older people it's
generally about the type of behavior the
order itself is proposed to be made for
three years subject to review
and just to give you an example it
doesn't stop people congregating it's
about behavior
and
what the order says is that the people
who are congregating of whatever age
shall not swear shout act in a manner as
to cause annoyance harassment alarm or
distress to any person within the
restricted area or land adjacent to it
or anyone living nearby
strikes me it's been perfectly
reasonable young people can congregate
as well as older people it's about the
behavior is not sectioning one group of
people from another
and i think the conversation needs to be
had about how we support timmoth uh and
i think this is an
appropriate and measured response to the
difficulties that have been experienced
in the town and from what other
colleagues have said by people of all
ages thank you thank you leader
councillor russell
i mean i i just take on board everything
that has been said um it's not an easy
decision to make but
the representations to the town council
have been so strong
and in fact um uh there was an assault
on on a ebola uh last year
by you know a group of young people uh
which was quite alarming at the time and
it was dealt with by the police and it
is a recorded act
so um something times things can get
really out of hand and it needs to be
curtailed thank you thank you thank you
casa russell councillor mcgregor
councillor mcgregor
ah thank you chair sorry i didn't i
didn't hear you there my internet's
playing up a little bit i just wanted to
to come back on the the um the youth
side i would like to pay tribute to the
children who cleared up the skate park
after the storms with very small brushes
uh clearing away sand and
detroiters from the the promenade and i
think that's a testament to the youth of
timothy as well that they are prepared
to muck in and get stuff done
thank you councillor
sorry councillor mcgregor councillor
wrigley you'd like to sum up now thank
you chair um thank you councillors for
all of those contributions uh uh
councillor malone and swain yes
absolutely about uh working with the
youth and councilor cox for bringing up
all the different uh aspects there
i too am impressed and amazed by the the
the young people within tinmath they are
coming out and doing all sorts of things
some examples we've heard of today
this is not an action aimed at young
people
this is not also the only action
the council continues to support many
more positive interventions and more
subtle interventions with things like
our turning corners programs and many
other community safety
programs that continue on helping people
to try to intervene before they get into
trouble and that is a much better route
and we will obviously continue to
promote those and push those in favor of
getting to this point
this pspo has been deemed necessary and
i think you've heard the testimony from
tinmuth counsellors
all over
and it is about
preventing the antisocial behavior that
is coming from abuse and misuse of
alcohol and other substances
is not about suppressing the youth and i
think it would be good if this council
can think in future and work in future
and i'd like to ask ons
to look at what we do do in terms of
youth provision across the patch and how
we can improve that and what we can do
in the future and that would be most
welcomed
but in the meantime this is a necessary
action to help prevent the anti-social
behavior and the abuse and misuse of
alcohol in the specific areas of tinmath
and please support it
thank you councillor wrigley so uh a
proposal from councillor wrigley
seconded by councillor linda pedrick can
we go to the vote please
counsel austin
councillor bradford
or
council villafant
councillor clarence
cancer colclough
oh
cancer connect
four
councillor david cox paul
councillor hugh cox oh
councillor doors
oh
counselor eden
councillor evans
four
councillor foden
council goodman bradbury
four cancer gribble
cancer haines
or
cancer haze
or
cancer gordon heck hook
[Music]
counselor jackie hook
or
councillor jeffrey
councillor jeffries
councillor jenks
mcgregor
yeah
cancer morgan
council malone
against new south wales
council naturally
or under the council
or
council at warm
cool
cancer parker khan or
cancer patch
four
cancer pit
four
council linda pedreck
oh
cancer persa
paul
council rollerson
or
councillor russell or
councillor spain four
councillor taylor
councillor thorne or
councillor team
four
councillor wrigley
councillor parker
or
cancer john pedreck four
that's carrie chair
thank you for that um item nine on the
agenda
the recommendation from the executive
notice of motion equality and
representation this was a notice of
motion that we considered some months
ago
um
and now it's recommended back to us by
by councillor nina jefferies um i'm
going to invite councillor nina
jefferies to to present it to us there
are actually 11 parts to this so i'm i i
hope that councilman jeffrey's
presentation covers the 11 parts and
that we just need to vote once once on
this item counselor jefferies
thank you chair um i'm not going to read
through all 11 parts because everybody
has got the paperwork and i feel that
it's gone to enough committees for all
councillors to know that so i just
briefly want to make a statement and an
update
and um i've got a couple of excerpts
from members of the community and
community groups that have written to me
that i'd just like to put forward in
support if that's okay
um so i just want to firstly extend my
thanks to everybody that's worked on
this and that's to all members of staff
within the council and those on
committees and counsellors that have
worked on this motion there are a huge
amount of parts to this and an
incredible amount of work has gone on
um
this motion today continues to reflect
our commitment our continuing commitment
to change
um i've said before a couple of meetings
that 2020 was fundamental in bringing to
the fore the experiences um and
representation
of those of us in diverse communities
and what we face
and those though issues have by no means
gone away um
though you may sometimes see them in the
press from time to time but i'm still
getting um feedback from children from
parents from community groups from
friends and colleagues of their
experiences and right across the board
um and some of which are still quite
upsetting obviously to hear
um
[Music]
so today i'd just like to read an
excerpt
from a community group that has come
forward from chudley
um and i felt that their letter which
has been an open letter was extremely
interesting i just wanted to read a
short part of it just thanking us for
the work that we're doing on this notice
of motion really so
um it's from search which is a social
and environmental action around chudley
some of you may know of this group will
be involved with it
um so they've written to me to just say
thank you for the work that we're doing
um and to bring to my attention some of
the work that they're doing in chudley
and what they're committed to
and their work was brought about they
say
by uh recent events which prompted a
number of people from the community that
are of color to share their personal and
heartfelt experiences in their town in
chudley they told of the racism they
suffer on a regular basis ranging from
direct explicit abuse to more subtle
insidious discrimination
some have shared that chudley was the
worst place for racism that they have
experienced in their lifetime
they these are painful collective
memories amongst us and they're
obviously recognized by this group and a
long-standing issue and chuckling in
their experience
they find the situation desperately sad
and unacceptable and they condem in the
strongest terms any form of racism in
our town and we stand in support and
solidarity with the victims of racist
abuse
so further down here they say they thank
us
cambridge district council that we have
um changed our policies and resources
and that we've enhanced um in october
and july respectively to racism in our
communities so i just want to
finish with
i'm sure you will agree that um
it's quite difficult to listen to and
read and i'm sure many counsellors have
had similar letters like that from
constituents when they've heard that
we've been working on this or may have
spoken to their friends or family
members about the experiences people may
be having and one of the main ways of
tackling um racism and discrimination in
any communities go straight to the
policies first to look at how we're
dealing with that to make sure that
we've got the opportunity to discuss
things openly um for people so i'm just
saying today thank you very much again
for everybody's work on this and i hope
that you will accept this notice of
promotion
thank you i would like to second please
chairman thank you so counseloric
um i i've worked on this as well with
sally and lina and that i i'm gonna
support it but just on motion number
seven which did come to our group
um
number two do you have an equalities
policy yes or no if yes please upload a
copy
i've had conversations with a couple of
people
and the questions being well does that
mean if you haven't got one you won't
get a grant so i wondered if we could
put in brackets there will not affect
your application if you haven't got
something like that
please
would that be acceptable council of the
jefferies yeah that's absolutely fine
it's not supposed to cause any confusion
but um
that's fine but rather than have an
amendment yeah okay go to the patch
thank you um chair um i think i think no
one would um question um the the the
validity and and um where this is coming
from this motion and there's this
sentiment and the aims of it um i just
have um one particular point i'd i'd
like to
raise regarding um on the section which
reads motions number two and four under
the paragraph uh bracketed four which um
talks about reviewing the um curriculums
for primary school through gcse level um
etc
um
i i just i'd wonder whether a word um
might
might render this a bit um
a bit unrealistic and unachievable um
just to read it um it says review the
primary school gcse a level national
curriculum with a view to ensuring that
the historical record of the british
empire is treated in a way which fully
takes account of slavery the actions and
views of historical figures etc um i
think if um well firstly i'd recognize
that we're not pedagogical experts we're
not um sort of um versed in advising
national government how to revise
specifically the curricula and i think
if if the word fully is included then um
i do fear for primary school children in
particular that uh will be overwhelmed
with this material where
because of the fact that if we were to
fully take accounts of slave reactions
of historical figures etc there would be
no room in the curriculum to teach
anything else
so while i think there ought to be a
recognition of these issues i would
suggest maybe the word fully um might
not sit comfortably there
jeffries are you happy to accept that
slight amendment
yeah if i could respond as well
um
having being a child that grew up in
this uh
society in devon actually and going to
school here councillor patch i would
have loved to have some
um
education about my own history within
the classroom um and as an educator and
teacher
i've written curriculum and i know how
easy it is to include it
thank you just for clarification um
chair i i'm not um disputing that this
needs to be included i i just question
um setting forward that um it fully
takes account of of all of these issues
because as as i said if it were to fully
take into account the extent and scope
of these very important issues there
would be no room in the agenda for
teaching anything else
thank you councillor patch councillor
mcgregor
thank you chair um just wanted to um
come back to a point made by councillor
linda pedrick regarding the um
the equality policies that
small groups might have or not have and
just asked whether or not we could as a
council
um have support in place should they
require any assistance because small
groups applying for small grants don't
necessarily have the resources in place
to put him
in you know um
put into action a process that gets a
fully
detailed equality uh policy in place and
it'd be nice if we could support support
groups so that they are getting the
support they need to to get it right
first time
thank you council malone
uh thank you yeah like councillor patch
um if i have a problem with any of this
and i do like him um
appreciate where it's coming from
uh it's with the parts motions two and
four
and uh a decision to start uh
teaching the oppressive truth of the
british empire in schools um now since
uh since history and schools was taken
over by sort of frankfurt school
politics and eric hobbs born we haven't
learned anything about the british
empire in schools for for years
certainly not since i mean i grew up in
the british empire i i wasn't thought
about it in schools i don't think any of
us were so it's not even on the agenda
so i don't know what where there's a
point of we have to start looking at it
in a different way
when we're we're we're not looking at it
at all at the moment now if there was
something i mean i appreciate we're
having to be economical with words and
not go on and on here so it's not
covering everything but it seems to me a
little bit um
simplistic if there's something i think
a starting point is put if you want to
put the british empire on on the
curriculum then that's a starting point
i mean there are some
great books
on the british empire this one is one of
the best and it's written by crazy
quoting who is from ghana and there are
some great books on the british empire
written by you know former colonial
subjects but they're about history you
know they're about history they're not
about
uh
senses having a sense of victimhood and
they're not about uh pseudo sociology
and they're not about um
social engineering which i i i i kind of
get a sense that this is we're going to
talk about history talk about it
as history um i don't have any fondness
for this sort of toxic vogue of making
our children feel like they're either
the sum of their grandfather's maladies
and either from a bloodline of
victimhood or heirs to tyranny and abuse
what you're doing there is taking two
kids who are happily playing together
and telling them how much baggage they
need to get over before they can carry
on i i i think we're going to talk about
history you know talk about history
before i moved here i lived in peckham
and i do miss my children having that
diversity
and i think one thing we haven't
mentioned here maybe because it's too
obvious is that for bame people you know
devon is still the wild west really and
you have to be very brave to move here
simply because you'll be part of a group
that's very sparsely represented so i
think what we need to do more than
anything is i think about how we can
welcome those that are pioneers and
choose to come and by all means target
those groups with you know a move to
devon campaign i'm all for diversity and
i'm all for those who are here having
the comfort of greater numbers but i
think we need to concentrate on sharing
our bounty rather than sharing our white
guilt uh that's the over
riding feeling that i have from this uh
but it's mainly with parts two and four
i do uh fully support the the thrust
and and the reasons behind uh the motion
thank you thank you councillor
a number of members have indicated they
would like to speak i think it would be
appropriate perhaps to invite councillor
jeffries back at the end to sum up
you're okay with that council of
jefferies fine so the next person is
councillor bulevant
thank you just a point of um
clarification really
was totally understand and support the
idea of all of these motions
in our procedural rules
um 493
motions must be about matters which are
related to the responsibilities of the
council we're not responsible for the
education system that's a devon county
council issue
can we phrase these in a way which gives
us the focus without breaching the
procedural rules that we have
because we're talking about issues we
have no control or input into
i i think that this refers to the leader
of the council right into the secretary
of state for education
well i'm looking at four and uh two and
three here oh sorry
uh motion numbers two and four sorry
um
again we have no responsibility for
education so i just want to yes we
should do it
but
how should we could we do it in a way
which doesn't contravene our um
procedural rules that's all i'm asking
i think it's just
it's suggesting the leader of the
council writes the secretary of state
for education
and if i can help chairman um i think
cancer bulletin is partly right motions
are not just about the council but about
the district
and regard to two and four as you quite
rightly point out the request is as
leader of the council i write to
the secretary of state for education uh
on what is that four five and six uh
which is well within the gift of the
council
is leader to do i'm happy if that's the
case thank you for clarification okay
thank you for that
councilor eden
yes um hello everybody um
i'm reminded of that expression don't
let um perfection be the enemy of good
what this and i fully support it what
these
um do and i'm referring back to to the
school education one is seek to address
a a a a
a proof a massive gulf
in the understanding and education of
all our children and it's to add in the
word fully if you take out fully you get
left in the horrible civil service rel
possibility of someone saying oh we've
taken account of it look it's a footnote
on page 305.
what what what this very well worded
suggestion here does is it it shifts it
shifts a situation where where at the
moment i feel like we're talking about
inc including our communities as though
it's a sort of a bit of an afterthought
that maybe we will or won't do
history is is not a history is difficult
people can defy people could try and
define what history is to their cows
come home but we know that we have a
problem with racism we have a day-to-day
problem we have pakis go home written in
the sand cancer reading please
what well i think that that was a rather
unpleasant that remark then you didn't
it was an unpleasant fact of racism that
i'm drawing attention to and if we try
and hide in the shadows about what's
actually happening in our streets our
beaches and our classrooms and inside
our homes we are failing our diverse
community and we become even more
irrelevant please let's pass all of
these measures they are the beginning of
something very important necessary and
good
thank you councillor eden thank you
councillor parker khan
thank you chair um
i i think this is a really important
motion and i wanted to address the bit
about
numbers four and five
um around the educational element and
again somebody said it already and this
is about writing to the secretary of
state rather than drafting curriculum
ourselves however it's vitally important
that we do have that broad and balanced
overview of historical events
not to abortion blame not to proportion
guilt for those of us who shared your
mixed heritage you don't want to war
within yourself but it's important that
there's really clear representation from
both sides from all sides actually so
that you get a full picture of things
that that went on and this my full
support in all areas
thank you
sarah parker khan
councillor cox
so jim we don't need to import um
ethnic minorities and people of color
of color uh my daughters are are mixed
race they were born in devon they are
the young devonian women are and they
are women of color and i find it
slightly offensive and you know and as a
parent i've had to deal with some of the
the horrible ugly race bar racism so
let's pass this and pass it as it is we
really do need to get over get over some
things i i'm
so appalled what's going on here you
know this is we need we need to fight
racism now
and here and we need to stop sweeping it
under the carpet it really is you know
frankly there are people still out there
and we need to face that and forget
moving statues fight racism today not
from what happened a hundred years ago
and you know as i say uh this council
had terry falco as a member before we've
you know really you know we don't need
to import people people you know and we
need to treat people as people we need
to end racism and i think what council
jeffrey says bravely and
you know must be very personal for her
has done with this has been really good
and i think we should back it one
hundred percent
thank you councillor cox
councillor patch
thank you chair i just wanted to come
back with a um a procedural point of
following up councillor bulovan's point
and then the response i know that
motions two and four um as has been
clarified um are allowing the league of
the council to write to the secretary of
state um for education
um
i'm not sure the leader needs our
permission really to to write to the um
secretary of state um
in his position of leader um
his predecessor was a great letter
writer um on various issues to members
of the government and i'm not sure that
on each occasion he had to ask
permission to the council to write
letters so i'd just like to reassure him
that um if he wants to write letters in
the future he doesn't need my particular
sanction
thank you councillor perhaps i mean it's
a recommendation
counselor wrigley
thank you jay i'll be very brief i just
want to say i fully support this no ifs
no buts no other weasel words and it's
time we did this and did this quickly
and i'd like to thank all of the people
on this council who have worked on this
i'm proud to stand by this motion and
fully support it thank you councillor
councillor malone
hi i'd just like to clarify you know
we're all we're all um
i don't think any of us uh have any
truck with racism i don't think uh i
don't think we should suggest that uh
those that are questioning what's the
wording of what is a very long document
after all uh do so uh
that's a little bit i i'd also like to
agree with the councillor patch the one
part that i had an issue with and that
he has an issue with is simply a letter
which i think you know
if the leader of the lib dem executive
if if this reflects his thoughts i think
he can just uh stick a stamp on an
envelope and pop it in a post box i
think that's so
so i i i think my my my reservations are
moot in any case thank you thank you
very much councillor rollerson
thank you chairman um i
want to support the the sentiments of
councillors cox and wrigley and others
that say we should accept this motion as
is and because nina and all those that
have supported her in the production of
it have done a fantastic job and it's
such an important issue it really does
have to be dealt with now and we take it
in its entirety thank you chairman thank
you thank you very much indeed
um the leader of the council
um
thank you chairman i was just a little
bit um
so i should come back on what councilman
said yes i could put a letter and stick
a stamp on it stick it in the letterbox
but
actually the import of this is the fact
that the council spent some time
considering this motion and has asked
his leaders to write on behalf of the
council um
i'm not just another white face trying
to say what it's like for people the
good thing about this motion is that
it's come through a lot of reflection
and it reflects the combined thoughts of
the council because i'm alone if you
don't agree you too can stick a stamp on
a letter and write to a secretary of
state and tell him what you think too
but my job if council want me to do it
is to write to the secretary of state on
behalf of the council i think that
carries some weight but wait the central
state will put it i don't know but i
think it's another
message to government about the way we
would like to see things happen i'm
sorry you may not entirely agree thank
you chairman
thank you for that leader members
unconscious of the time that this is
taking there are another two people that
want to speak for the second time
councillor mcgregor
thank you chair but you know also as a
parent of mixed-race children i i just
really want to to emphasize i think the
effort and work that's been put in by
councillor jefferies and others has been
absolutely commendable i will
unreservedly support this this motion
um
i would like to to just say that i think
it's important that in writing a letter
and sticking a stamp on an envelope that
the leader has the full support
of the council
um and i i would like also to think that
we can work with other councils around
about the work done by councillor
jermaine ate alia down in in bay uh it's
very similar to the work that councilman
jeffries is doing and it's really really
refreshing to see that we are starting
to make some inroads into this
really rather um difficult subject and i
think it's so it's commendable that the
efforts have been made and i i really do
commend uh councillor jefferies on this
one it's fantastic work thank you thank
you very much indeed councillor jeffreys
would you like to sum up now please
okay i'll be brief i mean just from
hearing the debate today although it's
gone round to numerous committees
numerous times and all of the points
have been discussed and agreed before um
it is clearly quite an emotive subject
still and one that is not going to go
away so as long as we have um transient
communities and movement within the
districts of all types of people this is
something that we still need to continue
discussing whether it's educationally
environmentally or any other reason it's
always going to be around there will
always be diverse communities and we
will have them within our local
community and we're gonna
thank you very much i hope that this
gets past today thank you very much
indeed yes so what we it's been proposed
and seconded so members can we go to the
vote please
chair there's a couple of uh amendments
that members have suggested yes and i
wanted to know um if councillor jeffries
um and councillor morgan who seconded
were um happy with those before we go to
the vote
now the first one was proposed by uh
councillor linda pedrick which was
motion seven and it was to do with the
um
the equalities and then we wanted to put
in brackets um
if you do not have what a policy um it
will not affect your application so
councillor jefferies were you happy to
take that amendment to the
recommendations on yes
and what's councillor morgan were you
happy to support that
yes
okay and then the second proposal
counselor patch raised
um and it was in motion um two and four
um and it was about the word uh fully
um
counselor patch um
i don't know if there's a proposal or a
suggestion
that the word fully be removed from that
um
notice of uh from that wording
counselor jefferies was that something
he wanted to take on
so excuse me i didn't present that
formally as an amendment i was just
making a point term really about the use
of that
okay thank you well um we'll um
disregard that one so it's just the one
amendment yeah okay
so there was another amendment that i'd
heard from the leader that motions
number two and four the leader of the
council right to sector states uh for
education on behalf of the council which
isn't actually in the original motion so
if that's what the sentiment of the
council is i think that ought to be on
the motion okay councillor patch when we
write and then notice emotion has been
agreed it's it's always really clear
that the motion was agreed by the
council so therefore um that is that is
put in the letter anyway
okay thank you for the clarification so
can we go to the vote now please
answer austin
councillor bradford
paul
councillor bill evans or
cancer clarence
four if i can excuse myself from the
meeting please i've got another
appointment thank you thank you
councillor colclough for
councillor connect
four
councillor david cox or
cancer hugh cox
councillor doors
four
cancer eden
cancer evans
four
counts of foden four
cancer goodman bradbury
four
cancer haines
poor
cancer hayes
oh
cancer gordonheck four
councillor jackie hook
or
cancer
jeffrey or
cancer jefferies
or
councillor jenks
or
cancer keenan
four
cancer kirswell
or
cancer
mcgregor or
cancer morgan
council malone
yeah four
councillor natalie or
councillor
or
oh
counselor persa or
councillor rollerson for
councillor russell
[Music]
councillor swain
port
councillor taylor
okay thank you for that members i'm
conscious at the time and the fact that
we have another four items on the agenda
so i'm going to suggest that we take
another 10 minute comfort break it's now
1 30. could you all be back for 140
please
and please switch off your microphones
and uh video before you go thank you
chairman can i give my apologies for the
rest of the meeting i have to take my
husband to an act patients appointment
most certainly thank you
and i'll have to do the same chairman
not for the same reason no that's okay i
hope your back is better colin yes
thank you very much i just say i'm
probably gonna have to go in about 20
minutes anyway okay well okay
can i apologize if i'm going to be laid
back because i i'm i'm um single
parenting at the moment i have to feed
several kids
hmm
chair um it's uh
ten minutes has gone by so um going to
have to do another roll call to check
here
okay yeah thank you
councillor austin
councillor bradford
president
councillor bullavent prison
cancer colcleff
[Music]
councillor connect
president
council david cox
president
cancer hugh cox
councillor doors
present
cancer eden
councillor evans president
councillor foden
council goodman bradbury
president
councillor haynes
cancer hayes
council hockey
counselor gordon hook
counselor jackie hook
counselor jeffrey
councillor jefferies
cancer care as well
mcgregor
president and councillor eden sends her
apologies cheers mcgregor
uh council malone
rosen
councillor natalie
councillor nuttal
present
cancer um
cancer parker khan
present but i will have to leave just
before two for cobia recovery meeting
i'm afraid thank you
cancer patch
president
cancer pete
president
councillor linda pedreck
president
cancer person
cancel the team
president
cancer wrigley president
councillor john petherick
uh president thank you
uh councillor hayes he's a present sir i
am present now uh
okay
thank you councillor
and council hayes thank you for that
thank you my internet just dropped me
out and i've had to log back in
sorry about that
thank you members for for rejoining um
item oh we have to do a roll call now
we're sorry we've done the roll calls
um
the next item on the agenda is a
recommendation from the executive
retention of the 20 pound universal
credit uplift and i understand that the
leader will move this recommendation
chairman i'm happy to move forward
everyone knows what it is in terms of
his content it was councillor cox's
emotion and i defer to him to speak to
hopefully briefly thank you chairman
okay thank you
councillor cox
thank you mr chairman i'd love to so
to second this i hope uh
hope that the council will support this
unanimously um there is a cost but the
20 pound uplift to
universal credit and we're suggesting
that it's kept and is extended to
legacy benefits that will in fact go
down because legacy benefits will move
across to universal credit
it will cost about 6.4 billion pounds
and there will be an additional
1.9 billion
uh for uh for that but the impact and
the effect it will have will be
brilliant um it will lift half a million
people out of poverty stop them sliding
into poverty including
two hundred thousand children
from a teenage point of view we've
amended our um
council tax so that people don't lose
what they gain from this and also if
people people who are who are on poorer
means tend to get this extra money they
tend to spend it in local shops and it
will help our local economy so we'll
have double benefit to us so uh it's got
support across the political spectrum
nationally and i hope that we can do
that at this council and ask the
chancellor who did the right thing who
increased the increased it by 20 pounds
uh you know he did that in march 2020 i
think
and that was the right thing to do to
keep it going uh to stop people falling
into poverty we don't we still aren't
out of the woods regarding the kovid
pandemic and there's likely to be a
recession afterwards we need to
show show that spirit that we've seen
with people working together uh in team
bridge working together as volunteers
volunteering for the first time um doing
things they never did did before we're
looking at sort of in my nick of the
woods kra doing doing sunday lunches
which something they never did before
david matthews
so i would ask i would ask that the
council supports unanimously the uh
the 20 pound uplift be retained and
extended to the legacy benefits
thank you uh councillor cox just to be
clear that you're you're recommending
that we write central government
yes that's that's correct okay okay
counselor mcgregor
thank you chair um as somebody who's
worked in welfare to work historically i
think it's very important that we
recognize that when people get into a
rut it's very very difficult for them to
get out of it
i know that there's been some um
information that's come through from
council
nina jefferies to the exec and
you know in in terms of support that's
being developed in getting people back
into work or upskilling or re-skilling
but it's very important that people
don't feel that they are being held back
as well by the simple need to balance
whether they can heat their home or feed
their children and i think it's really
important that we do support this and
i'll be supporting it wholeheartedly uh
and in terms of the the motion going
forward and the the leader writing to
the to the secretary of state
thank you councillor wrigley uh thank
you chair yes just very briefly this is
so important to the uh
uh
most needy in our society and um 20
pounds a week is a massive uplift now
one of the things to remember is that
that sort of money goes instantly into
the local economy as well so not only
does it help people and not have them
make to make the choice of heating their
house or feeding their children
it means that we can also support our
local businesses i will be supporting
this and i urge everybody else to do so
as well thank you councillor wrigley so
no nobody else indicating they want to
speak so can we go to the vote please
counselor austin
council austin
councillor bradford
council relevance
council colclough
four
councillor connect or
cancer david cox four
councillor doors
or
councillor evans
or
cancer foden
cancer goodman bradbury
four
councillor haines
four
cancer hayes
or
cancer gordon hook
boar
cancer jackie hook
cancer jeffrey
cancer jenks
for
cancer healing
four
cancer care as well
or
cancer mcgregor
or
cancer malone
councillor nutsley or
councillor nuttel
[Music]
or
cancer team
or
councillor wrigley
four
councillor john pedreck
perry unanimously care okay thank you
for that
thank you colleen
i item 11 on the agenda
recommendation from the strata
joint executive uh councillor wrigley is
going to present this recommendation
uh thank you chair so what we need after
a three hour long council meeting is to
go in depth into the uh minute details
of our it budget for hours upon end
so i haven't prepared no i don't it's
okay so i'll be very brief we have
looked at it at strata's
business plan
for the next year this went through our
joint executive
committee and the scrutiny committee so
it's been looked at twice by our
committees
strata as you'll recall is our joint i.t
provider between the three councils in
order to approve their work each year
this needs to be approved the business
plan needs to be approved by all three
councils
we are in the deal with strata it was a
10-year deal it runs up to 2024 so this
is a continuation of where we are
we have
taken out some things within here that
we
considered not necessary and stripped it
back and we are down to five things that
we are asking this council to approve
alongside exeter and east devon
that is the list of proposed savings in
their budget
the hardware budgets
uh being returned to east devon district
council and team bridge district council
appointment of a data analyst post
benchmarking undertaken by the society
of
citm which i cannot remember what it
stands for the industry body that does
it
and the mechanism for work
prioritization
strata budgets are set up in an
extremely strange manner in any way they
show their spending or bits and pieces
they call it savings
it's down to the way it's constructed it
is very confusing to look at and uh um i
really wouldn't uh ask you to
give yourself a headache by trying to
figure out why
in in essence this is the minimum budget
that we need to provide the services to
take us forward and to deliver what we
need from strata
in a couple of years time we need to
have a debate about strata and the
future of it so that we can determine
after 2024 what we do
but this is what we need to approve
today to continue the operation of not
only our council but the other two
councils as well
it was gone through in quite some detail
by the previous two committees that
looked of it looked at it so i now put
it in front of you for your approval
and uh would like to ask for a second
please
i'll second that chair thank you by
councillor mcgregor thank you councillor
boulevant
just a quick point of clarity please can
the portfolio holder explain why teenage
counselors pay 400 pounds a year for
their computers when east
have them provided free by strata and
why team bridge councillors have to meet
the cost of all their station
requirements when each account aged them
have their costs covered by strata as
well please
counselor that's not an item in the
report in front of you nor is it under
consideration right now
the arrangements for ipads i think
you've brought up before that was a
decision made by the
previous administration and in fact
councillors do not pay for their ipads
but i think we'll probably uh differ on
that
okay do we have a proposal and it's been
seconded
can we go to the vote please members
counselor austin
councillor bradford
stein
council bullet against
cancer doors
cancel the doors
sorry abstone
councillor evans
four
cancer foden
or
cancer goodman bradbury
four
councillor haynes
or
cancer hayes
or
cancer gordon hook
councillor jackie hook
councillor jeffrey jane
councillor jenks
for
cancer keeling
for
cancer care as well
i'm staying
cancer mcgregor
yeah
cancer malone
abstain
counselor natalie yeah
cancer nuttel
four
councillor orm
abstain
cancer parker khan
dane
[Music]
cancer patch abstain
counselor pete
abstain
counselling to pedorec
council persa
four
council of rolison
or
councillor russell
against
cancer swain
four
council taylor
cancer thorne
councillor
against
cancer wrigley
council john pedreck
can i just check how barrel austin voted
please
it i just wanted to check but it's been
carried chair okay
thank you for that sarah
item 12 on the agenda members allowances
i refer you to page 109 to 114 of our
agenda
and i request now that the member for
corporate resources councillor keeling
presents the
recommendation thank you mr chairman
the irp the independent remuneration
panel
recommends to full council that the
following changes to the membership
allowance scheme
with effect from the 3rd of september
2020
one the special responsibility allowance
for the chairs of overview and scrutiny
by a multiple of 1.1
and vice chairs of new and scrutiny
committees be a multiple of
0.3
2.
the special responsibility allowance for
the chair of licensing and regulatory
committee be a multiple of
0.75
and the vice chair of licensing and
regulatory committee be a multiple of
0.4
and 3.
the special responsibility allowance for
the voting executive member without
portfolio be a multiple of one point one
thank you mr chairman
thank you ozil from cancer the keaney
would somebody like to second that i
will chairman thank you seconded by
leader of council
cancer agent patch
come to the patch we can't hear you
i'm sorry about that chair um
um yeah i'm just saying that i'm sure
that many of us can recall reasonably
well the debate that was had not that
long ago regarding the splitting of the
overview and scrutiny committees to
create two committee where there was one
beforehand where lots of us were
very steadfastly unconvinced of the need
for this um
and the extra expense indeed that that
would um
incur now i'd also put that alongside
the provision of the non-voting
executive member for the um conservative
representative and looking at the table
that set out um in the papers
that those together add
14 were in excess of 14 000 pounds
to the um budget for sras now the
changes that um sort of many might might
see is um not actually required to
improve the functioning of this council
that that fourteen thousand pounds in
excess of fourteen thousand pounds
constitutes more than ten percent of the
sra budget
now i'm just sort of placing this in
context of the um
the sort of um hand-wringing about the
expenses uh rather the state of the
budget that we heard earlier on to
justify uh what what some might see that
sort of token to the virtue signaling
gesture of um sort of not having a cost
of living increase for members
allowances so at the same time as
increasing the budget for sras by 14 000
pounds
now um
councillor dawes used the word a short
while ago chamocracy it's not one i've
come across before i should have to look
that up but in terms of the creation of
an extra um czech committee chair and
vice chair filled by lib dem members and
the extra
extra
sort of paid role for the um
conservative member on the executive
um
i do sort of have in my mind questions
of um does this reflect somehow jobs for
the boys or rather sort of um council
taxpayers money for the boys um and i i
would suggest um that and and the paper
set out um in in our um document pack
suggests that um
we might want to put forward alternative
proposals i would suggest that if those
um if extra expenditure for those roads
is to be included perhaps overall the
allowances for sras could be reduced pro
rata to account for that extra fourteen
thousand pounds has gone on to the
budget for
sras i'll formally move that as a
proposal
sorry you're making an amendment then
i'd like to put that forward as an
amendment if anybody would be minded to
back it
i think you're gonna have well we'll
come back to that later but i think
you're gonna have to define exactly what
you're saying in the council about yeah
because that's what i'm happy to do that
the um in incorporating the extra um
sras for the extra um chair of ons the
extra vice chair of the ons and the
exposition of non-voting member
executive um that the 14 000 pounds or
in excess of 14 000 pounds um
expenditure on the sra budget that comes
as a result of this
that this 14 000 pounds that that figure
be used to pro rata reduce down the sras
for all members to receive sras so that
um the the decision to
create the new um position for the exec
member and the new committee does not um
incur the sexual expenditure
so councillor patch has proposed an
amendment is there a second of the
council apaches amendment
i'm happy to second them
okay cancel them alone
uh councillor bulevant
um as i'm personally
affected by one of these decisions i
don't think it would be appropriate for
me to take part in any voting on what um
decisions the council chooses to chooses
to adopt the only question i would ask
is that there is a comment about the
legal implications could we have just
next uh a broader expansion of
what those legal implications are please
the avoidance of that i'm talking about
the
on page 109
before making any changes to its
allowances scheme
just what are the implications that uh
the solicitor is referring to
so do we have a legal representative
present
you're muted sarah
it wasn't the person that actually made
the comments on the report
um
i understand that they're implying that
you know you just need to have um due
considerations to the independent
remuneration panels recommendations
um
but as it says you can have any
alternative you don't have to take on
their recommendations
okay thank you
leader of the council
um
thank you chairman uh i think councillor
patch has misguided himself
um
the 14 000 refers to the full cost if no
change is made
if i take members back to the meeting
last september council agreed
to create two
overview scrutiny committees and it also
agreed to abolish one of the regulatory
committees
so that was abolished
the appointment to the executive is a
gift of the leader uh or in the
responsibility of the leader
and members may well recall that i said
at the september council meeting that
any appointments made
in terms of the new committees etc would
have to be dealt with on the current
members remuneration that existed but we
would ask the independent remuneration
panel to meet early and to make its
considered
recommendations back to council is what
these are chairmen so in essence the net
increase cost of the special
responsibility allowances is not 14 068
pounds seven thousand one hundred and
seventy seven channel that's the full
in-year cost
what council patch may also have
neglected to consider is the fact that
the council has met uh virtually uh
since uh first lockdown um is going to
continue meeting virtually at least
until may unless the government extend
it so there have been no trouble costs
uh for the council so there is a saving
both in
current financial year and in the first
three months of the next financial year
so this should be broadly neutral
chairman now the important consideration
then is how does the council wish to run
and the two of you scrutiny committees
i believe are working well and doing
better than one large one and certainly
we
changed the licensing and regulatory to
have one committee chairman so there are
demonstrable changes and benefits um and
the council can choose not to follow the
advice of the independent remuneration
panel and if councillor patch is happy
uh that the overall cost should be
fourteen thousand then that's the matter
for him to put there but actually the
recommendation of the irp
uh is that the changes that they are
recommending as independent people who
have considered
these matters is
a change in the sras
and this will give 7177
based on the changes that council has
made thank you chairman
thank you councillor patch
thank you chad um i'm sorry that the
leader um misheard what i actually said
i did not um state a net increase figure
i i added up the figures in the table
that's presented in in the report of the
um the new post for the ons committee
chair the new post for the um deputy
chair of ons and that the new position
that's been created on executive that
comes to in excess of 14 000 pounds now
i did not um assert that as a net
increase figure um there is a net
increase though which results from
these overall changes um
and
i would for simplification let's look at
the net increase then figure i would um
so maybe word my um proposed amendment
in terms of there be no net increase in
the figure and in order to do that
to incorporate the new positions created
then perhaps the existing positions and
all positions be prorated down so the
overall budget for sras is the same as
it might otherwise have been without
these new positions having been created
so you you're no altering the wording of
your amendment councillor patch can you
just redefine exactly what it is and
i'll ask councillor alone if he agrees
with that
sure okay that um the the overall budget
for ssras
taking into account
um the uh the notion not to have an
increase in the overall budget as a
result of the creation of these new
positions
but instead a pro-rata adjustment to be
made to all sras so the overall budget
for sras remains as it would otherwise
have been without the creation of these
new
thank
positions
are you content with that amendment to
the amendment council malone
um i'll i'll be honest it's it's
the wording was slightly beyond me so it
might be best if someone else seconds
this motion oh
so
would somebody like to second cancel the
patch's motion i'm happy to second the
motion okay and you're happy with the
amendment to the amendment yes okay
thank you thank you for that
go to the doors
uh uh thank you i'll just uh
lower my hand
um yeah
all i wanted to say was the the
backtracking and talking about what
uh
what fees were paid uh some time ago i
think it's just the sort of smokes green
and some element of confusion about this
i think what what council apache is
talking about are real monies at this
point in time uh and proposing to to
have real savings um
taking the point of the
the two o and s groups work well that's
a matter of opinion i think many people
would disagree with that uh and when the
two o and s groups came into being it
did squeak through on the tiniest of
votes in the good old days when the lib
dems had a majority so
i'm not sure that's going to be a
prevailing view for very long
but i am happy to uh to back back uh
everybody's amendment thank you thank
you councillor malone
uh thank you i i think however we slice
up the sums here the the optics of this
just aren't very good we're at the time
when you you're saying that the common
foot soldiers of the members should uh
you know uh take it on the chin there
isn't any money you know fair enough but
then why are we doing this and and and
and i will never understand why there
exists a non-voting conservative place
on the executive uh i don't think it's
affordable i don't think it makes sense
and i don't think it's politically
healthy uh politics
when it's healthy
is adversarial for a reason and to an
extent it must remain adversarial this
has the uh appearance of a sort of uh
club at the top and uh
it doesn't look good and i wouldn't want
to vote for this
thank you councillor councillor keeling
thank you very much mr chairman and can
i say
that
my position on the executive was voted
in by the group it wasn't appointed by
anybody um and i was very pleased for
the support of my group and and that is
the same for each executive member we
all voted into place and for clarity can
i just
explain something for the public more so
that
the independent remuneration panel
is made up of five
five representatives from our community
who are business and voluntary sector
they're not connected in any way in fact
to to be on that committee if you were
putting yourself forward as a counselor
you wouldn't get onto that committee so
these are independent people that have
looked at this and and don't forget we
you know we've just turned down
um you know a pay increase as such which
is it you know very small compared with
the hours that each of the executive
members actually put in
and can i also say that you know
the the counselor stephen bursa has been
invaluable on on that executive
invaluable and i have spoken to him on
many occasions and he is you know is a
professional
accountant in a previous life as such
and well respected on this council well
respected as such but i just thought i'd
put that clarity
in there also on committees
um councillors reflects that you know
the chair and the vice chair are voted
in by those committees they're not just
given
as a given they are voted in
thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor keating councillor
cox
thank you mr chairman in my in my
professional uh life i always recommend
that trustees claim their um travel
expenses and their meal announces and
why do i do that because people make a
virtue out of not claiming their
expenses and not claiming their things
because effectively it means being a
volunteer or being a trustee for charity
it excludes people who are poor because
the people who can afford to but not
take expenses embarrass the people who
do who would need to take expenses to
contribute something to a charity when i
was very very young i was an officer
cadet in the territorial army and i was
doing my officer training i didn't claim
my pay and someone said to me quite
rightly i was being very selfish and
they were quite right because i could
afford to do
serve without taking pay without taking
travelling things not everyone could do
that and it's quite right that people
are who do voluntary work are not out of
pocket before because of it it isn't a
king's ransom that uh
executive members get they put an awful
lot of hours in and and councillor
persona has been invaluable council
person i remember council person been
involved in the um the credit crunch
when we thought credit crunch was the
worst thing to happen to a country been
involved in that council person's um
great uh abilities and uh knowledge and
it's because because of those none of
this political affiliation these on the
executive are important to this council
we have to pull together but to get
through the pandemic and we're quite
right to put councillor purser on on the
uh executive so at the end of the day
the council will end up
because of the travel savings on travel
will end up uh no worse off for for
doing this and i believe that the the
two overview scrutinies do increase the
efficiency of the council
quite right to combine licensing and and
um uh i sing
and the others i think those committees
needed to be put into one and that's
worked very well so i think i think it's
working well i think it's right we
shouldn't be ashamed
to pay people
some renumeration for the work they do
and in fact in some ways it's selfish
not to because otherwise we would make
being a counselor as councillor eden
earlier i've said the the preserve of
the rich and the powerful or the retired
and we need a whole cross-section of the
of the community involved in council so
i think we should back this
thank you councillor cox um no more blue
hands so we need to go with the vote
first i'm sorry councilor
you need to mute yourself cancer alone
cancer you need to unmute yourself
i agree with the remuneration for um
counsellors who are poorer to encourage
them to be able to participate and fully
represent their communities um i will be
abstaining because i'm not certain of
the efficacy of two ons groups and i
wondered whether there'll be a review
um into whether this should continue in
its current format so um
i'll be up abstaining because i i'm not
sure that it works in this sense thank
you councillor councillor russell
thank you i mean i did have mohammed
before but i must have mistakenly put it
down again i'm pleased that allen had
referred to the independent remuneration
panel because and any
anything any queries really can always
go back there but it is a touchy subject
all the time people look at people on
the executive and i've been there myself
and they think you know you're getting
extra
but for your bit that you do but it's
it's a lot that people do on the
executive and um
you know you don't do these jobs lightly
and david's quite right uh to say that
we must we must accept the rules as they
are but if there is a really serious
dispute then there is always an
alternative uh review panel to have a
look at it and so i'm quite content with
what's going on thank you thank you
russell so we're going to go to the vote
now firstly on council apache's
amendment could you just if you wouldn't
mind councillor patch just refining
exactly redefining what exactly what
your moment is please
certainly okay um so that um the overall
budget for the sra
not to be increased as a result of the
creation of an additional chair of ons
an additional
advisable deputy chair of ons and the
creation of a new opposition executive
role
and in order
for that um for those creations not to
increase the
overall sra budget
then the all sras to be adjusted pro
rata in order to maintain that
budgetary figure
are you okay you've got that sarah have
you
that's fine yeah and that's to be a
second did by council of doors that's
right thank you so can we go to the vote
please
counselor austin
counselor bradford
or
councillor bullavent
i already said it was inappropriate for
me is it yes sorry apologies
uh councillor colclough
abstain
cancer connect
cancer david cox against
cancer doors
or
cancer evans
against
councillor foden
against
cancer goodman bradbury
against
councillor haynes
i'm staying
councillor hayes
again
cancer gordon hook
he's left the room he's not voting
thank you councillor jackie hook
council jeffrey
councillor jenks
cancer keeling
against
further centers council obviously i'll
abstain from this item all together
cancer care as well
abstain cancer mcgregor
against him
yeah
councilman
one that's two
look
councilman sorry four
natalie james
councillor nuttal
against
councillor
abstain let's say
cancer persa
uh in view of it's about me i should
abstain
councillor rolison against
councillor russell yes
swain
abstain
cancer taylor
against
councillor thorn
abstain
cancer team
four
councillor wrigley
against
councillor john pedreck against
that's lost chair that amendment
okay thank you so we need to go back to
the original recommendation
from councillor keeling
um
could you just redefine what the
recommendation was it's the record sorry
it's the recommendations of the
remuneration panel is that correct yes
that's correct mr chairman as set out
yeah and who who seconded that i'm
determined that's okay
can we go to the vote on that please
answer austin
councillor austin
councillor bradford
against
cancer colclough
against
councillor connect
councillor david cox or
councillor doors
councillor evans
paul
councillor foden
cancer goodman bradbury
or
councillor haines
war
councillor hayes
cancer jackie hook
cancer jeffrey
jane
cancer jenks
again i'll abstain
cancer keeling
or
cancer care as well
stain
cancer mcgregor
or
cancer malone
against councillor natalie or
councillor nuttel
four
councillor
abstain
cancer patch
against
four
councillor russell
councillor swain
abstain
councillor taylor
four
councillor thorne abstain
that's carrie chair
thank you very much thank you
item 13 on the agenda committee seats
and political balance
so i'm looking for a proposer and
seconder
um to
to recommend
um the committee seats and political
balance as set out on page five of the
agenda
the chairman i'm happy to uh propose
a second
yeah thank you chairman um i didn't
indicate that i
um to sam that i intended to raise this
issue
um
members will recall that when we had to
go into this situation after the 2000
act that the independent group was set
up
in order to get the correct seat
allocation although obviously the group
does meet to discuss other things
the first and we've only had this is the
third
non-aligned uh council we've had since
that time
the first one rhona ironically couldn't
take a seat on planning because at that
time the council decided to apply um
more strictly the regulations in the in
the act so there were no seats for
people who were not part of a group
um i think i was about seven years ago
james left the conservatives and became
a sole ukip councillor on the council
but at that time we offered him a seat
as the council and um i believe it was
on scrutiny at the time but can't find
the electronic records they don't go
back that far to see if that was the
case
um
i first of all i wonder whether uh
councillor has been asked if they if
she's got a preference for which um
committee she wishes to be on
looking at the table the differences are
only to sort of two decimal places
and if you look at the actual act it
says
determination so far as reasonably
practical practicable
uh to the principles which is the fact
that they should have the same
proportion to the total number of seats
on the on the council so um what we've
got here is a situation where if you
look at it in the table that that has
the um
the no group it's 0.34 is the highest
one so therefore planning seems to pop
up as the
the one that should be chosen because as
it happens now planning is the largest
committee i know all the other figures
would have to be re-jigged and don't
worry i'm not going to propose
anything different today but i want to
flag this up so that it can be
reconsidered
for the um the meeting in in may
um
if if we know what um counselor or
sorry um counselor eden's some
expectations are perhaps we could have
addressed that rather than just saying
right you're on planning and maybe maybe
she has been asked
but if i could go back to another issue
that's been raised in the previous item
this is the the two overview and
scrutiny committees which members may
recall and i think it was um council
doors pointed to this it was a fairly
narrowly
approved thing uh when there was a lib
dem majority there isn't a majority now
and one looks at the figures there
and the total number of seats that the
lib dem should have across the two
committees now is actually
12.72 and not 14 as is on the table
there that's across two committees um
and uh indeed that that was what was
being proposed back in july at our
original annual meeting but then that
got changed um to the one in september
uh to what um gave the independence one
seat on the scraps try to scrutiny
albeit the figures at that time actually
indicated that it should have been a
second lived mc
so what i'm driving at here chairman and
and we have now got a new committee
that's going to be formed shortly the
constitution committee which presumably
will have to go on to this table as well
in due course
um we may look at recombining the
overview and scrutiny committees as was
indicated earlier in what people were
saying and it was sold to members or
given to members of the view that it was
just see if it works or not i know some
members in my group have expressed the
view or not and that's been expressed
again this afternoon
so it may be that that will be
recombined so when we come to review it
all and there may have been other
changes in numbers by then um it's only
a few months between now and the annual
meeting i will certainly be raising this
then
and i expect to see um account taken of
what the wishes of any um unaligned
member is so that they might have their
their wishes addressed if that's
possible that's all i want to say at
this point general i'm not going to
propose any any amendments but i don't
particularly um see it as being
a good form as it currently is thank you
councillor haynes
uh no other members have indicated that
they would like to speak so can we go to
the vote please generally just don't
summarize before
would that be all right thank you just
very briefly um councillor haynes is um
i think stretchy elastic on what this
item is actually about and i understand
that and as i said in september there
will be a time to revisit what the
council's structural arrangements are
and what committees there are and
council made reference a bit earlier
with regard to this item
um
the issue is this simply because council
eden has become non-aligned
the liberal democrats have lost a seat
on planning actually jenks came off and
that's where the vacancy is it's a
straightforward matter
the council will obviously be looking at
the whole of the committee structure
again
because of the decision to create a new
committee
and that when that comes back and of
course we have the annual meeting
presumably in may um
no reason to think it wouldn't be so
these will be looked at again so what
we're looking at is
uh as is should be the council having to
make a decision about where a
non-aligned member sits and and it's not
a new seat on planning it's in place of
a liberal democrat member to my mind
very straightforward and i would
encourage members to support that thank
you
thank you leader councillor cool
yeah thank you chairman yes i i was put
my hand up to agree
entirely with councillor haines i think
he's been very patient waiting until may
to have this decided because if he put a
proposition forward today i would have
seconded it um i think he's entirely
right i think it's all got to be looked
at again and i hope
that the
suggestion of two ons committees comes
up then because i don't think we're all
very happy about it
even if some of us are so you know i'll
wait till may along with councillor
haines but
i do support what he says
thank you councillor kocov can we go to
the vote now please
counselor austin
councillor austin
four
councillor bradford
against
council bullevent
councillor bill evans
councillor kolcloff abstaining
councillor connect paul
councillor david cox or
cancer doors
dane
councillor evans
paul
councillor foden
oh council goodman bradbury
or
councillor haynes
abstain
councillor hayes
or
cancer jackie hook
counselor jeffrey
cancer jenks
cancer keeling
four
cancer care as well abstain
council mcgregor
or
hanson malone
cancer natalie or
counselor nuttel
staying
counselor pitt
councillor linda pedreck
councilpersa
councillor persa
four sorry
councillor rollerson
or
cancer russell
councillor swain
four
cancer taylor
cancer thorne
cancer team
or
cancer wrigley
or
cancer john pedreck
that's carry chair
thank you
item 14 on the agenda waiver of
six-month cancer attendance
counter-attendance rule
it's recommended that the council
considers the request to extend
councillor cook's period of office
beyond the six-month
period of non-attendance provided for
within section 8-5 oblique one of the
local government act 1972 on the grounds
of ill health for a period of three
months to expire on the 30th of june
members councillor cook is a colleague
of ours and i hope that you will join me
in giving her our support and empathy at
this difficult time
councillor patch
thank you chair yes i'll echo that
sentiment and obviously it's it's always
sad to hear if a member is suffering
from ill health in any way and um i i
would extend um those sympathy sub to
her and indeed her family um
i i i'd have a couple of questions well
i have a number of points and questions
but um firstly some procedural questions
um has um
the counsellor made a formal request for
an extension to june um of this
six-month period um and if so um
has why has that not been circulated to
members um secondly this is obviously
not a notice of motion um as i can see
no proposal and supporters it doesn't
appear to be a recommendation of um a
committee i just wondered um what what's
the um how has this um come onto the
agenda has has someone put this forward
gentlemen if i can explain yes um so it
wouldn't be a motion or indeed come
through the committee any member of the
council facing some circumstance in
their life whether it's a marriage or
breakup or perhaps even prolonged
absence because of a job
um can apply to council for a leave of
absence uh that would be made to the
proper officer or the chief executive
for a better description
and then that's placed on the council
agenda which is what's happened here
uh i wouldn't expect members to receive
the letter which may contain personal
information i've not seen at the letter
but councillor cook has made the request
and it's before members today for their
consideration
uh thank you very much um may i come on
to my substantive points at the
procedural um points have been addressed
sorry carry on coaster patch okay thank
you chad um
and again i'll preface this with um um
sort of sympathy and communications um
for the counsellor um
i i just do wonder um whether this
request is is being made really with the
um interests of um the best interests of
the councillor uh councillor cook
um and indeed with the interests of the
residents of um king's car as well who
and and let's not um forget that the
nature of this provision um in the 1972
um act local government act is to ensure
that local residents do receive
representation at council so i just
wonder uh the balance between the the um
sort of having been mindful of residents
interests being mindful of counselor
cook's best interests um balanced
against um might there be a need um
in the minds of liberal democrats to
maintain a seat i'm on the council the
name of the um
liberal democrats i do i do i have
questions in my mind about the balance
of the motivations um for this that has
been delayed to some extent now that um
we've heard that the request has been
made by councillor cook and it's not an
initiative um by someone else within the
liberal democrats but still i am
concerned that this provision was put
into law to ensure representation of
local residents and um with a would a
three-month extension to um sort of i
know just just beyond may the um sort of
when the local elections are um
um
the fellow sort of lib dems confident
that come june councillor cook will be
um in in a position to be able to um
come back and um fully represent um her
residence
i'm not able to discuss uh councillor
cook's sort of medical history with you
because that's medical and confidence
but i am confident that she would
returning in three months time yes
as as a as a um as able to represent her
residents absolutely yes yes
thanks to the
um we have a colleague now who needs our
help and needs our support and who's
asked for an extra three months so she
can recuperate
and get back to full health and i i
propose that we support this
uh thank you council of public would
somebody like to second that proposal a
second chairman
thank you councillor rollerson seconded
councillor boulevant thank you when one
of our colleagues is ill
we deserve to give them the
consideration
and the care that uh those people need
and i'm pleased with the assurances from
the chair of the council plus the lead
with the the leader of the council
that
um councillor cook will return to her
duties with a full
uh full recovery within three months if
that is given to her and i therefore
would be very happy to propose that we
do give her three months to come back to
this council
uh it's been proposed already
yes
i appreciate that yeah okay thank you
councillor russell
well i just wonder whether why it's on
the agenda at all chairman uh in the in
the public or even like this i i just
don't see any need for it whatsoever
we have had people who have been off ill
for uh various reasons certainly in the
conservatives we've had some serious
illnesses and sadly we've had deaths as
well
through illness and but we've never had
to come through a committee to get
permission to uh help them do that and i
just don't like that thank you
councillor russell councillor mcgregor
thank you chair i i just want to to
emphasize perhaps on on the position
that uh councillor connect has been
particularly
uh impartial on these issues and advised
another councillor who'd received
um
you know invasive surgery that they
could also take a leave of absence uh
for a period of time and that person's
not a member of the libyan group and you
know i think it's important that we
steer away from
uh
petty politicization of of this kind of
issue when it's we're talking about a
real individual here
um you know i'm just really looking
forward to having sheila back
and i think we should all support really
her best efforts are getting well thank
you
thank you councillor mcgregor cancel the
doors
because the doors you're muted
or you're quiet sorry yes i wasn't right
i'm back now sorry sorry about that yes
i i
i pass on my sympathies and hope that
counselor cook will be able to come back
and serve our residents the the reason
it's on the agenda and we have to bother
ourselves with that is because this is a
democratic process and there is an
absolute obligation for us to act in the
best interest of the residents now we
have been reassured through this process
that uh that the likelihood is the
council can make it full recovery and
come back and represent the rest so
we should we should be we are we are
reassured by that but just to brush it
out and say we shouldn't be bothered
with it is almost in the front to
democracy sorry
thank you councillor dawes catch them
alone
sorry yes um
yeah i just think i i don't think
there's anything we can really debate
here is that because we don't have the
knowledge of whether three months will
bring an improvement or a diminishing of
her circumstances and we can't know that
so it is
it's very difficult to um
for for us to have any meaningful debate
um
i i think what there needs to be here is
either a hard and fast rule on the six
months or a hard and fast rule that you
know
any any reasonable reason given will it
will always get the three months
extension
what concerns me is that where there is
that wiggle room it may be extended to
some people and not to others um
but and i think there should be somebody
perhaps in charge of uh
of making a sort of value value judgment
on that thanks
okay thank you councilman so it's been
proposed by uh linda patrick councillor
linda patrick and seconded by councillor
rollerson that we approve the
recommendation so can we go to the vote
please
counselor austin
council austin
or
council bradford
david cox or
yours
sorry i'm going to abstain
counselor evans
four
councillor foden
all
council goodman bradbury
or
cancer hayes
cancer jackie hook
counselor jeffrey
cancer junks
or
cancer keeling
four
cancer care as well
four
council mcgregor
four
council malone
abstain
counselling naturally or
cancer nuttall
that's not warm
cool
cancer patch
cancel the patch
abstain
cancer pit
council linda pedreck poor
cancer persa
or
councillor ronnison
or
councillor russell
councillor swain four
councillor taylor
or
councillor thorne
oh
that's carry chair
thank you very much indeed for that
sarah
well members that concludes our marathon
meeting for today four and three quarter
hours
um hopefully i'll see you all at the
members covet recovery workshop on
friday the 26th that's this friday at 2
p.m so look forward to seeing you all
then
goodbye
all right
yes thank you mr chairman hi
thank you